there's no time time
is 13. o'clock
[Music]
hey everybody what's going on
if you guys hear explosions it's because
it's there's it's storming outside
i mean there's [ __ ] thunder this is
like the third storm we've had today
yeah actually yesterday was pretty bad
too
it was and it only rains for like i said
it's like the monsoon season really
rains for a few minutes
and it's like right and it's like
[ __ ] lightning flashing like hitting
the neighbor's house it sounds like a
damn bomb went off just [ __ ] above
them
damn sound like a 155 going off
but um so hopefully we won't lose the
stream
yeah because sometimes power outages
happen
nature nature might kick our asses right
tammy says got my cookbook today it
looks great thank you so much yay
i got a message from esther as well she
got hers too so i'm glad you guys
like it awesome yeah i'm getting uh
private messages and stuff for
people taking photographs of their them
with their cookbooks
people seem to be enjoying it some
people girls laugh and tom has hair in
the face
when i had hair i guess i guess i guess
some of these kind of knew
when i took the photos yeah when i took
the photos a couple months ago before i
shaved my hair
yeah i shave my hair my i shave my head
every now and then every couple years
i'll shave it
and you hear that [ __ ] holy [ __ ] goddamn
was that
sounds like the apocalypse yeah although
like i said it's just florida it sounds
like this pretty much every day
around this time we're kind of used to
it it's scary but
it's you know we kind of get used to it
it takes me a while to
to get used to being bald you know yeah
i shave and i go oh man i don't know if
i really shouldn't maybe i should have
done that well too late
like a couple weeks later i'm like nah
that looks good like that
well i mean it is kind of like although
it's not that weird for you because i
mean you always had really short hair
it's not like you were going around with
a big old dirt bullet like your wig
no a lot and then you just shaved it off
a little short too yeah
short or whatever so anyway today
we got a pretty good show this is about
uh missing airliner
the malaysia airlines flight 370 the
famous
this [ __ ] went off into a parallel
universe
it don lemon on cnn said that it went
through a black hole
so therefore it happened
oh stank figures that didn't call it
stink fingers
you put putting his sticky fingers in
people's faces you hear about that
no okay that's a lot he got he got into
some legal trouble for that
anyway so we're gonna uh talk about some
of you guys know what i'm talking about
i i certainly do not but um but okay
this wouldn't be the first time
yeah sure yeah you don't know what's up
with you don't know what's going on but
uh that
i do it's just i don't know what's going
on in those you know
yeah yeah that was pop culture
online pop culture but anyway uh so
we're gonna talk about that
and then um do we have anything uh
that we needed to plug all i wanted to
say oh and don't let me forget like at
some point during the stream
yeah um i need to i don't usually show
like show ads anymore but i do actually
have an ad to show
good for the strange realities
conference
yeah that's adam saying our friends over
at conspiranormal
and they're having their yearly
conference which i actually did a thing
on last year
it was in i think it was in october or
november last year and it was all online
uh this year they're doing a combo
they're doing like they're doing it in
person it's in nashville but they're
also doing some event online too
so you know so i got an ad so i got to
play that at some point so please don't
let me get like so [ __ ]
hammered that i forgot to play the ad
new trailer for uh
dune drops yesterday i saw it today it
looks badass
i like it yeah i gotta watch that i
thought i sent you didn't i send you a
um no i just told you about it didn't
they yeah you just told me yeah i don't
know even if you did send it i don't
check facebook
there's a lot there's a lot more in this
one and you can see there's a lot of
if you like the dino de laurentiis
version you're not going to be
disappointed
they show you what people look like you
me you recognize certain scenes
the flying fat man everything and it
looks good it looks really good
i mean i'm excited yeah the atreides
uniforms didn't change all that much
uh the knife fighting uh yeah it looks
really good
the only trailer that i saw today was
for the new m night
uh shyamalan movie called old
which i guess is in theaters now i'm
supposing because it looks like some
people that i watch online have already
seen it
so thank you david june here's a plug
for tom's awesome pliskin shirt thank
you that's i got this the large plastic
label you're a large place yep if you
guys are interested i'll send you one
for about
for a 20 super chat sandra world
champion in dwarf tossing
she changed her name she's a world
champion in dwarf dawson does she toss
male dwarves or female dwarves it must
be females
she's in the female wrestling right
i'd like to suppose i'd like to i'd like
to see sandra wrestle some female
dwarves i'm gonna [ __ ]
we're gonna we're gonna call my friend
we're gonna set that up
yeah sandra said we'll tell you when
we're halfway through the show jenny so
after three hours
play the [ __ ] ad right yeah um yeah i
just kind of like
the thing about this case in particular
was that i remember hearing about this
on the news when it happened right back
in 2014
and i remember it being like mysterious
like that they hadn't found the plane
and everything but i hadn't really
fought and i knew there was like a lot
of stupid conspiracy theories about it
like there is about everything these
days seemingly
but i hadn't really like followed any of
the [ __ ]
or so i didn't really know what was
going on with it
so the last few days i started like
reading everything i could
read on and i watched like a [ __ ] ton of
different documentaries like australia
did a 60 minutes
about it there was like another [ __ ]
australian documentary about it it was
just like all kind of stuff
and if what happened if what they think
happened
is what happened it's pretty [ __ ]
creepy it's not paranormal or anything
like that
it's just like really really creepy and
like i said it's i think this scared me
the most
because i hate hate
flying in planes and flying in planes
and after
listening to this story like what
probably happened on this [ __ ] plane
i never want to fly on an airplane ever
ever again
because it just sounds like horrific
it's just i don't know i just i i just
don't want anything to do with it
it's so so scary i don't know why it
bothered me so much it just really
really bothers me
anything to do with like plane crashes
bothers me so
you know what i mean but you know like i
said i'm just saying right from the gate
i don't think it went through a black
hole it didn't like get kidnapped by
aliens
you know it's all the conspiracy
theories about it are dumb
there's like tons of evidence like
pointing to one particular thing that
happened they don't know exactly why it
happened because it's super weird but
i'm just saying
sandra's talking about smooth and
crunchy peanut butter again did you get
did you uh do that peanut butter shake
like i said with the vanilla ice cream
oh that [ __ ] is so good it is really
really good yeah making me try to
pull out some [ __ ] peanut butter
talking about i got that whole
jar a damn goober grape i still didn't
even open it because i have so much
other peanut butter and jellies sitting
around we have so much [ __ ]
butter in this house i mean it's like
we have so much everything it's like you
can't i only eat like once or twice a
day so it's just kind of like all this
food is just kind of sitting there
yeah you know this shelf stable though
well i know yeah yeah
camp guy says i got some almond butter
at costco i love almond butter
actually yes and i still have um a
little bit of cashew butter left as well
which is also delicious
i have that for breakfast every now and
then on my toast yeah i bet you i bet
you
i bet you sandra has never heard of
cashew butter
or almond butter we're gonna get her on
the other butters
butter butters the other butters
[Laughter]
really good uh oh come craft and chat
with sally ann says loving listening to
you guys my first time here while i'm
sad having a glass of wine oh cool
all right salute we're having what what
even is this this is cherry vodka and
what it's cherry vodka with apple juice
grape juice um
what's that stuff uh
not passion fruit what's the other stuff
that i had in there mango
no guava guava yeah and a little bit of
um cranberry and then cherry vodka
it's fruit potch yeah it kind of tastes
like very very boozy
yeah for one punch kind of probably
would have been
tasted it was good it probably would
have been better with that uh coconut
vodka
well everything's good with coconut
vines right tila says the harshest plane
ride i flew through a storm at night
over texas thought
we were going down i always check for
the flight attendants to gauge how to
react
i had the same thing happen it's like i
was not actually i wasn't
scared of flying until one particular
flight where i was flying from orlando
to london
and we were midway over the atlantic
ocean
and we had super super bad turbulence
the kind of turbulence where you could
like actually feel the plane dropping
like several hundred feet and i was
wigging out everybody on the plane was
wigging out and even actually some of
the flight crew were
looking a little nervous so i was just
kind of like oh goody i just really did
not want to die this way of all the
[ __ ] ways
christ so it's like it's i don't know i
think i've said this before but it's
like it doesn't bother me as much
if we're over land i don't know why it's
like you're still gonna die like if you
hit the [ __ ] ground
but for some reason like being over the
ocean it's just kind of like oh there's
something like so so creepy about that
and honestly maybe that was one of the
things that creeps me out about this
case is that
i mean i know the ocean's big and
everything but the fact that they
haven't
found the wreckage they haven't found
any of the bodies now they have found
pieces of the plane
um or that they're pretty sure from that
plane but they haven't found like the
bulk of the wreckage and they haven't
found any of the bodies yet
either um they pretty much they kind of
know
i think the thing about it and we'll get
into this in a bit for a while
because of some incorrect
uh information they were the first
searches that went out were looking like
way in the wrong place
so now that they actually kind of know
like from other like satellite data and
stuff like that where
the plane actually probably went down
maybe they'll be able to find it but i
see you know it's in the indian ocean
somewhere and it's just kind of like
the ocean's a big place y'all and it's
like really really hard to find [ __ ]
and that's like a really really remote
and really um
like the weather is really bad in that
part of the uh of the area where they
where they ditched it where it got
ditched so you know there's that whole
situation too they probably will i was
watching one documentary
and there was one guy on there that said
as far as commercial aircraft go he's
not talking about like military aircraft
or anything like that
but as far as like commercial aircraft
go it's like this is the only plane
that they haven't found it it's like
sometimes it takes a while like to find
it but they always find it but this one
they haven't found it yet
but it's only been since 2014. so we'll
see how it goes
what nothing yeah
putting my [ __ ] my my sexy gloves on
that's sexy and everything up
your sex you're sexy sexy everything up
those [ __ ] girls oh and you have
shorts on
and i got shorts on so somebody might
ask you to go get something
off the shelf so she said she could see
your
get the legs i'm just trying to get
sandra fat
thank you tb drinkers what do you say
just because i love you guys
thank you very much we love you too
thank you very much very much
you want to go ahead and start with the
case i mean we got a good crowd in there
yeah yeah yeah
um no they're getting antsy they're
getting ants they're getting asked oh
one thing i did want to say was that did
you notice we hit 11 000 subs
i didn't notice yeah i think sure
yesterday
i think it was we like went two or three
over i don't know what it was this
morning because i forgot to look
but uh yeah we finally finally got it
for eleven thousand so yay
go ahead and plug that cookbook real
quick before we start jaden show them
the cookbook
if you guys have not seen the cookbook
everybody's enjoying it
um and of course jenny makes all
different kinds of books
that the new cookbook is in all right
look even pokey and beijing are on there
and uh it's got [ __ ] all kinds of
stuff man it's got southern classics
yes probably half of it is like southern
food and then there's like indian
food mexican mexican food chinese
thai food i'm just like looking for a
picture that's what i'm doing
just quit rushing me oh i thought you
were trying to show it to him no no no i
was just i was looking for something
that was like a good picture
yeah yeah he doesn't
think that i know what i'm doing yes
it's even got some indian food in there
and
um really that's very attractive
cookbook if you're outside the united
states too like if you really wanted to
know what americans really eat
not that [ __ ] you get at mcdonald's
man we don't eat that we eat
yeah we do we'll eat that we really
eat that and that is not american food
we're like really desperate yeah like in
a hurry not true american food that's
[ __ ] corporate food
we more like that that kind of stuff
especially if you're in the south that's
got southern classics in there that at
the north
and even in california they knew nothing
about that
nothing mrs evans already party says ooh
how do we order one
just go to lulu.com
and search cooking time with 13 o'clock
yep
dj maniac asks what is your actual
relationship like with beijing the way
you talk about her on the streams it
sounds like she loathes you
no she's very aloof she's just very very
aloof yes
honestly though this morning yeah i came
in here like before it was like really
early and i came in my office like
and i was getting some food ready for um
because i go on my walk and i take food
for mr mcguire the path kitty
so i have some cat food bags stowed in
here and beijing
and pookie were both like kind of laying
in the living room like beijing was
laying very weirdly like by one of her
little scratching posts and pookie was
up in the chair
and i was like hey beijing all right
because she was just kind of like
whatever
and then like i was in here getting some
food and she came in here and when she
was started like talking to me like
and then like she laid down and like let
me pet her which she hardly ever does
yeah usually like she'll let you pet her
she's not gonna bite you or anything
but when you pet her she's always sounds
like she's complaining about it
it's not good enough oh
that wasn't really what i wanted it's
like it's always that kind of yeah
dude she's real skinny and fluffy
and real pretty and she knows it she's
kind of like the paris hilton the cats
but she's better looking than paris
hilton
she is she thinks that her she thinks
she's the [ __ ] god's gift
yeah i mean it's not good enough yeah
this is not it's not legible pookie is
is like a little kid and she's like oh
no i can't take it i can't take this
it's so funny that he tries to [ __ ]
sometimes they'll hang out like they
don't fight all the time yeah but
pookie can't resist that big fluffy butt
though so it's like every time the
fluffy butt like goes by i can see
pookie's little face going oh like
i need i really need to jump on that she
became a [ __ ] when we got pookie
she blamed me especially especially
because of me she blames me for that cat
she's a
yeah they're not stupid no they're
totally not they're not stupid they
they have personalities and they
understand dynamics and it's funny
because our two cats are just they have
completely completely different
personalities completely different
back to selling that book though that
cookbook
there's recipes in there real good
southern recipes and when i was living
up in boston
one of them right outside uh arlington's
square one of the hottest restaurants in
boston was a [ __ ]
southern restaurant called red bones and
it was barbecued
pork and [ __ ] kind of like fake
southern food it was southern inspired
food but they [ __ ] loved it i ate it
it was good
it wasn't authentic but it was good
cornbread was [ __ ] fluffy and light
and sweet
cornbread is coarse and bland it's like
eating sandpaper that's what it's really
like
but for some reason you like it it's
just no way to describe it
although i will eat either kind yeah
real southern cornbread is
not for tourists because boston market
would do those cornbreads that were kind
of that were real sweet and stuff but
those were kind of good though yeah
my dad used to make fun of that [ __ ] man
i said yankee corn cake
that's not cornbread that's cake you
know and he was right
we like the stuff that tastes like crap
yeah well
it's supposed to be not it's not
supposed to be not supposed to rise up
too much it's only about an inch thick
it's kind of coarse and dry and it's
cracks and crunches when you drop when
it's soft but
not really it's it it's like there's
grit in it
it's just pieces of corn cornmeal but
you use that to sop up all the fluids
and all the drippings from southern food
like
you know your but all that's in there
all that is in there and so if you're in
if you're
outside the south if you're in england
or in germany or
well i got one german already sold one
to her if you're any
you'll be able to get those components
and execute the the real thing and it is
good
and it doesn't cost much to make you
know the whole secret behind southern
food is
to make nothing taste like something and
[ __ ] eat like a king just on a few
dollars that's that's in there
and it's got real good mexican food
cheap jack stuff real good mexican food
that i cleared
through con of otsulon actual mexican
official mexican official mexican
official a fish he's officially mexican
all right that's my boy we're [ __ ]
he's we trade recipes a lot
he lives in tijuana yeah they're always
like talking about we're always talking
about it
he sends me pictures of his food and i'm
like god damn
yeah yeah funny because like we'll be
like in the bedroom watching a movie and
i see him over there and i just see like
pictures of mexican food popping up
constantly two things pictures of
[ __ ] mexican food and pictures of
nexus
girl's asses mexican asses yeah it's
like either that's a good idea
so what do you think of that one turn
around she looks good
she looks real good she goes that's what
we got here yeah that's that kind of
stuff
it's just guy stuff you know we do that
yeah yeah
yeah uh sleazy baby says how much is a
cookbook it's 35
dollars which is might sound like a lot
but that is
that that is a cheap cookbook actually
for for what
for for the level of production on that
it's good quality paper
it's color it's uh it's funny it's not a
dry cook but it's funny
it's got quotes in there from me yeah
the quote the book
the cookbook reads the way i talk so
it's
yeah that's what i try to do because i
kind of well i just recorded him talking
about each of the recipes and then i put
that
into with i put my own [ __ ] in there too
but it's like i've
kind of put that in written form yeah
and it got pictures of pokemon
everything pictures of me with knives
yeah dj maniac says well because he was
talking about beijing before it's like
we have pokey oh and this is beijing
yeah beijing is a lot older than pokey
well yes like a girl
woman she does you actually had beijing
before i even met you yeah because she
is an old woman now
yeah she's 13 i think she's 13. and um
like i said we don't she just doesn't
interact with us as much because she
just kind of like does her own thing
like i said she's very old so it's kind
of like well there yeah but there was a
lot of stuff that i wanted to uh
answer taylor said 10 super chat saying
team sweet cornbread because it's payday
i like the sweet cornbread too my dad
made fun of it he calls it corn cake
yankee corn cake he would deride that
[ __ ]
but i would eat it but like it's not
cornbread though it's corn cake it is
good but it is i don't care what it is
it's good but that's not the real thing
and you don't ask
yankee corn cake to be cornbread you're
doing different things with that
you don't talk about yankee corn cake
could actually be
actually a dessert that's how sweet it
is
yeah but southern cornbread you dip that
into things
like you could dip that into [ __ ]
black-eyed peas or you could dip that
into the into [ __ ]
the drippings from say like [ __ ]
collard greens
you know so it's a lot more savory
you know it's just like mexicans
fighting over should it be a flower
tortilla or a corn tortilla if you're a
real mexican
it's a [ __ ] corn tortilla flour
tortillas are [ __ ] for californians
man come on
that's a northern thing i like them both
though
yeah they're both they're both well
they're both good they're both good for
different things yeah
sleazy b says is trail kitty still
around yeah i see him i didn't see him
today but i saw him yesterday
so i always take a bag of food just in
case and every time i take a bag of food
like he'll just be sitting there by the
fence and he'll just come out and start
yelling now i have to clarify i'm
talking about corn tortillas and flour
tortillas for tacos
everybody knows a flour tortilla is for
a burrito but when it comes to tacos
a southern mexican a southerner down in
mexico is not going to
like a flower taco that much you're
gonna want a
corn taco and having made my own corn
tortillas
out of corn masa and make it's a lot
better than a pre-bought
[ __ ] corn tortilla or this [ __ ]
taco bell [ __ ] when you make your
own tortillas
and i talk about it in that book you
make your own tortillas it's a [ __ ]
whole another dish
it's just a whole other world
yeah fourth throwdown says all cats
loathe their owners i don't know if
that's the case
what i was saying before was that
beijing
is just a very aloof cat she's just kind
of like i want to do my own thing you
try to pet her and she's just like okay
fine
that's enough that's enough that's
enough but pookie is like the total
opposite
she's just like constantly up in your
face up in your [ __ ] she just wants to
be like involved whatever you're doing
she wants you to chase her
yeah it's like if you're on the tablet
if you're like eating something she's
like sticking her face what you doing
what you doing if i'm putting laundry
away she's like what are you doing and
she's like clawing at the towels and
stuff she watches movies
she watches movies with us she sits on
the end of the bed yeah
and just and watches the movie she was
watching uh mid-summer with us
actually yeah mid-summer scared her
she was getting drawn in because she
knows what green and what form
she's out there and watched pretty much
that whole entire movie yeah she knows
what what nature looks like she can
recognize that if she sees a big
cityscape
she's never seen that so she doesn't she
can't relate to that she'll look away
but it's people running around and grass
you know and trees
and she she's looking at that and she
responds to the soundtrack
if it's getting scary she'd come back
she'll look back at us yeah eyes
is it okay is it okay can i look at it
yeah it's gonna be well the thing that
freaked her out in midsummer the most
with it was funny
we were watching it last night was there
you know for a couple sequences there's
like
a baby crying yeah background and that
was really bothering her yeah
she kept like she didn't move but she
was like sitting at the end of the bed
and she kept turning around like
eyes like this big with her with big
eyes like is that okay
he's crying yeah why is the baby crying
yeah
i don't think she knows what a baby
crying is but she knew that that was
something wrong
she knew that that was bad because a lot
of times because like i said we mostly
just watch
horror movies so there's always like
scary music or people screaming
people screaming or babies crying like
really same stuff yeah it bothers her
it freaks her out like not so much that
she's gonna run under the bed but she'll
like look at us to check and make sure
that well a baby crying sounds a lot
like a
rabbit being eaten or killed yeah yeah
so i guess that's kind of a universal
call distress call
right so she's going some something yeah
her eyes get super big
yeah something's wrong they're killing
it what's the matter where is it
where's that baby yeah i don't think she
knows it's a baby though i think she
might just think it's some kind of
animal
yeah she's never seen a baby yeah i
don't think she ever has no idea
no she's only four yeah i don't think
every nobody's ever brought a baby over
here so
she's only seen one young kid and that
was dimitri and
dimitri's daughter and she wasn't that
she was she was like 12 or something
yeah
she was mystified though like whoa she's
little
littler than an adult who's this little
person yeah
granthar's hammer says i hear pilots
sometimes intentionally cause turbulence
when they think a couple of passengers
are in the bathroom doing the mile high
club
wouldn't that be funny if they really
did it's like i don't know how you would
know
but it's like if somebody came to the
front and like told you like some [ __ ]
hey i think some people are [ __ ] in
the
tiny airplane bathroom why the [ __ ]
would you do that i doubt it those
airplane bathrooms are so [ __ ] small
and the pilot's like watch this
how would they know anybody was back
there that's right that's what i'm
saying unless there's cameras that would
be super funny if somebody did that
though
and and i think uh piling a plane is all
computer controlled i don't even think
they grab those controls the most part
yeah they i mean normally they don't
well normally they don't have to
you know what i mean because
everything's like pretty routine yeah
not much room in an airplane bathroom
it's
not even really much room for one person
i don't see how you can get too [ __ ]
people in there
yeah holy crap just pepper said
he's talking to me he says mexican food
and mexican asses are two great
commodities
[Laughter]
two great commodities butts and food
that's okay
yeah so did i say thank you to tila for
that yeah
well like i said it's like i was trying
to like answer questions and you kept
derailing me so it's like i got really
behind
fourth drawer down says eg hookers
cannot resist crack
everyone knows that frank hooker
that ought to be a shirt another shirt
but that say so much crazy [ __ ] that
should be a shirt
well that was a franken hooker though
yeah i mean or something like that was
in franken hockey kinda yeah yeah that
inspired i don't think he said that
though god damn it i love frankenhugger
i think i said that on the review i'm
like i ironically love this movie
yeah sandra says there are funny games
for cats that they can play on a tablet
maybe beijing would like those like
running mice and then try to catch them
i've seen those and it's like i wonder
if she would
play those yeah she doesn't i mean she
mostly just like lays around looking
pretty and it's like look how beautiful
i am
she has that kind of thing yeah but um
she might she plays sometimes she likes
to
um jump up the wall and like surprise
you
sandra mentioned and this is true that
beijing loves raccoons though that is
absolutely true
that is i walked out on the back porch
and three raccoons were looking
had walked out of the back porch moved
three or four and we're looking at
beijing and beijing was just she just
wanted to get laid i could tell she was
like oh you guys
are so cute we're going to get it on i
thought
those sexy raccoons yeah she was
definitely in on it she was into it she
was like oh
wow and she was up on the chair
looking down and the raccoons were
standing up on both legs sniffing her
and i didn't watch it long enough i
thought there was going to be trouble
but there wasn't as soon as i opened the
door they ran
off and she looked at me like well you
[ __ ] it up
we were hanging out yeah always heard
that raccoons are kind of mean but
i did more research afterwards than no
they're not mean to cats
they like cats they get along quite a
bit
that's really a lot of videos of
raccoons and cats now i did have a cat
attacked not by a raccoon though by a
possum a possum attacked a cat but
i don't know if the cat attacked him
first just pepper says i never thought
about it but mid-summer does seem like a
really good for an animal's attention
when animals get creeped out you know
it's good yeah
yeah she seriously and that's a long
movie that's like two and a half hours
i'm pretty
sure she sat there and watched most of
the movie yes you stand
she missed the beginning of it but then
she like came and sat on the edge of the
bed and she just watched the whole thing
it's all those nature
scenes i guess and the music she was
getting drawn into it
yeah she was like she was just like
sitting there looking at it like that
and she knows that it's not real
like you know what i mean because
sometimes you know we have the big tv
and it's like they'll be because i'll be
like look pookie there's a kitty on tv
she knows that's not a real kitty like
she's interested in it because of the
noises that it makes but
she doesn't go up there going oh look
it's a real kitty she understands that
that's
tina said she means a hoe she's not the
hoe what is she's just experimental
okay no no she just sees don't judge her
yeah yeah it was gonna be like an
interracial gang bang
you know oh yeah i'm into this y'all
three y'all
come on she's like look at your pretty
stripey tail and she hates cats
see that's the thing she does not like
other cats well because she wants to be
the most beautiful
yeah but she saw those raccoons and she
was super impressed
i think that's why she was so mad when
we got pokey because she's like pookie
is little and she's like really cute and
everybody's fussing over her
because we got pookie when she was like
tiny tiny and so she was like i'm
supposed to be the beautiful baby
yeah and now you have this other little
baby and i don't like that baby she got
displaced
yeah and she totally felt like that too
you could tell that was like her
attitude and
like i said she blamed you yeah mainly
because i think she held you responsible
you're bringing pokey into the house
yeah so it's like now every time he'll
bend him you'd be like hey bish what's
up and he'll try and she'll be like
she makes a noise like that she goes get
her [ __ ] away from me
she asked you for things but she doesn't
want me touching her she's like
stop that infection [ __ ] she's like yeah
you don't love me [ __ ] get up
oh my god still [ __ ] funny cats are
so funny they're
seriously they're hilarious but i was
gonna say when when uh somebody said
about the games like on the tablet
one thing that i don't like pookie is
interested in the tablet because tom has
it and it's like ooh who's that person
that's like on there she's interested in
that
but her favorite thing on that [ __ ]
tablet i think we've said this before
you have a piece of tape that's over the
like the webcam
and she is just adamant that she is
gonna chew that piece of tape off of
there
yeah and the weird thing he had an old
tablet and he put like a bunch of tape
all over and gave it to her
like as a toy and she was like she would
not play with it yeah she's like no i
want yours
yeah she knows that that wasn't my
tablet yeah she's like i'm gonna take
this one
because there's she's down here just all
the time going yeah
trying to get that piece of tape off
there all right so it's time to start
the show i mean [ __ ] the crowd is
still
is uh and it's zenith let's get this
[ __ ] out because we never hardly get
more than 40 anyway
all right so let's go ahead and start
this show so we're going to talk some
about this show
like i said i asked you before we
started you don't know hardly anything
about this i only know what i heard from
the news
and i didn't know like i said i remember
hearing about it in 2014 when it first
happened
and then i remember like there was a
mystery about it like they never found
the plane
but that was pretty much all i knew
about this particular case and still
until i started researching it and it's
just like
i can understand why it became this big
like internet mystery this big rabbit
hole and stuff
because it's just like what what the
most likely scenario is
is so creepy and weird
that you know it that's just gonna
capture everybody's imagination but i
didn't realize that they knew so much
information about what had happened to
the plane subsequently
i kind of thought oh it just vanished
and it's like oh it just crashed into
the ocean big deal
well you know it's a big deal obviously
but i didn't know that there was all
this other kind of um
weird [ __ ] that it happened like prior
to that okay so
we're going back to march 8th 2014.
it's 12 42 a.m now
this is a boeing 777
otherwise known as the triple seven and
this is a malaysia airlines flight and
it's taking off from
kuala lumpur in malaysia
and this is a routine flight going to
beijing china they do this flight two
times every single day
so nothing unusual about it at all
so this plane takes off at 12 42 am
uh goes up to its cruising altitude 35
000 feet
normal uh this is so
the so the guy on it there's like the
guy that was flying the plane that was
the captain was on the plane and then
there was also the first officer his
name was free kameed
um he was actually 27 years old and he
was what are you doing
he's trying to scroll down to where it
was okay oh thank you mr roboto yeah
aren't disappearing planes common enough
they are it's which is scary
but the reason for this one disappearing
was kind of crazy
i kind of feel like that's why and as i
mentioned earlier i don't know if you're
here but i was watching a documentary
about it where there was a guy that said
um
all commercial airlines that have
crashed into the ocean and [ __ ] like
that they have actually eventually found
all of them
even though it takes a long time but
this is the only one that they haven't
found yet
i do think eventually they'll find it
although
as far as i know like they called off a
lot of the searches
um in 2017 like there was some private
companies looking and [ __ ] like that so
i don't know if they're going to keep
because it does seem like most people
want to kind of keep looking at at least
like to know like where the [ __ ]
at least to get the bodies back you know
what i mean because they you know they
never did find anybody
so um yeah tila says disappearing planes
is extremely scary don't think it ever
cried
don't think it never crosses my mind
when i fly i see every this is why i
can't like i have such a hard time
flying because it's [ __ ] scary you
know and sleazy be said
he sent me some photographs he found
some magic mushrooms outside i think
that was the hospital
he says look at these and he's comparing
him he sent me the picture and it says
yeah that's them
he [ __ ] took the magic mushroom
started eating them
yeah i don't know if it's such a good
idea to just eat random ones it was the
most some of them are poisonous it was
the one
yeah it looked it looked like it looked
like it my dad was an expert at those
[ __ ]
a lot of people a lot of people are
there's a lot of people that go foraging
for mushrooms like in the woods you
gotta watch because like i said it's
the poisonous ones and the non-poisonous
ones kind of he was looking for the food
once
yeah yeah well yeah that's what most
people are right honestly if you can
find like some really rare ones some
like restaurants and [ __ ] will pay you
like yeah
money for those so he said he he found
some that were worth almost like sixty
dollars a mushroom yeah yeah
you know i mean you eat like a whole
bunch of them yeah so there's like a
whole subculture of people that do that
yeah like as a hobby he was trying to
make side money out on the deer
down out the deer patch because he kept
finding all these damn mushrooms and
[ __ ]
he turned out yeah some of that [ __ ] was
worth money yeah
yeah because a lot of like farm to table
restaurants will totally buy those off
you
um yeah so the first officer was
actually the one uh flying the airplane
when it took off now he was 27 years old
as i said his name was free kameed
this was actually his last he had logged
about i think it was about 27 hours
2700 hours of flight time this was
actually he was still a trainee
uh this was actually his last training
flight
in more ways than one and that's like
really horrible to say
but yeah this would have been his last
flight like after like after his
um after this one he wouldn't have been
like a trainee anymore you know what i'm
saying he would have been like a first
officer
now um the guy training him the one that
was the
uh pilot was named zahari ahmad shah
now uh they usually just call him
captain zahari because i guess that's a
malaysian thing where they just call
everybody by their first names
now he had been flying for malaysia
airlines for a really long time and he
had like pretty much a spotless record
um 53 years old one of the most senior
captains at malaysia airlines he um
was married had three grown children
lived in a really nice neighborhood he
actually owned two houses uh you know so
he had one really nice house and another
one
now one thing that will come into play
later on
was that in the house that he lived in
he was really
really into aviation like it was a big
big hobby it's not only these
fly plans for a living but it was also
something that he was really interested
in just outside of work hours
so he actually had um you know he was on
all these online forums about it
and he had a microsoft flight simulator
at his home that he used to like just
play with like all the time
and if you look he was really really
active on social media
like facebook youtube stuff like that
and he was really interested in aviation
like i said so he
had posted i don't know if they're still
there anymore but he had posted like a
lot of videos like talking about
different uh
aspects of aviation and stuff he seemed
like a super nice uh
dude and super normal so
so that's uh kind of the thing that's
going on so in the
cabin of the airplane there were like
besides the two of them there were also
10 flight attendants so that's 12 crew
members in total
uh all of them were malaysian citizens
in the passenger compartment of the
plane there were 227
passengers uh five of them were children
the bulk of the passengers were chinese
which is not
that surprising since the flight was
going to beijing
out of the rest of the passengers uh
that were not
chinese 38 of them were malaysian and
there were also
a few a handful from indonesia
a few australians some from india couple
french people couple americans
couple iranians couple ukrainians
canadian
new zealand the netherlands one russian
and one
taiwanese person so that's what was on
the uh that's what was on the plane now
so as i said the first officer was
actually the one flying the plane
because he was in training as i said
while the captain was
uh manning the radios not unusual this
was something that
you know often happened uh would you
know when
one of them was a trainee or whatever so
at this point so that so everything
seems fine
they take off from kuala lumpur
everything's normal the weather's good
like i said this is a very routine uh
route this is a route that they flew two
times a day
it was the middle of the night there was
one in the middle of the night there was
one in the daytime
so 101 am the captain captain zahari
he radios that they've leveled off at 35
000 feet
now this is a little bit unusual
but not enough to like make anybody like
suspicious because
normally what you would do is
i guess because if you're under like the
radar they already know that you're at
35 000 feet so normally you would just
radio in hey
you're changing your altitude not that
you're like cruising at an altitude you
know what i'm saying
so it's just so they thought it was like
a little strange but not that strange
so you know when you're leaving in
altitude you report not when you arrive
at an altitude that's what i'm saying
so seven minutes later
at 108 a.m uh the flight crosses into
the cross the malaysian coastline and
then started setting out across the
south china sea
uh in the direction of vietnam
and at this point the captain radios in
again and again
reports the plane's level at 35 000 feet
again unusual but not really
unusual enough to you know for anyone to
get alarmed
11 minutes after that um at 119
the plane is closing in on there's like
a um
there's one point where the malaysian
airspace would turn into the vietnamese
airspace right
and you're supposed to report when that
happens because you're being trans
you're being handed off to that other
country's air traffic controllers right
so that's just standard procedure
so basically uh the last thing that
happens so
when he's leaving malaysian airspace
uh the air traffic controller at kuala
lumpur
radioed to him malaysian370 contact ho
chi minh
one two zero decimal nine good night so
that's basically he's saying you know
now you're in vietnamese airspace so
contact them and tell them that you've
arrived
because they have a system where you
have to radio in you know for every
airspace so they know where you're at
and at this point the captain answers
and like i said you can listen to
uh you know the recordings of this which
are
super creepy since you know what
happened uh the captain
answers goodnight malaysian370.
um normally you would read back the
frequency
at this point but he did not um
his voice didn't sound weird he just
sounded like normal
but that's all he said good night
malaysian370
this was the last communication that
anyone
ever had with this [ __ ] airplane okay
so like i said if you listen when i
listen to it i saw a documentary about
it and they played that audio
and knowing that nobody heard from the
plane after that like every time they
played that clip it like kind of like
gave me goosebumps it was like really
really creepy
even though he doesn't sound weird he
doesn't sound weird
so yeah um now the pi
neither pilot uh checked in with ho chi
minh
and there were like several attempts
afterwards to raise them but none of
them were answered
now interestingly okay so you have your
regular radar which is primary radar
right and that's like you know pinging
off
objects that are in the sky just like
you know sound waves or whatever
now air traffic control systems um
they have something called secondary
radar and that is that comes from a
transponder
signal so these transponder signals are
transmitted by the airplanes and
this uh signal has all kind of [ __ ]
about
you know what airplane this is like what
its altitude is
blah blah blah um you know so it has all
this info that it conveys now
five seconds after this airplane crosses
into vietnamese airspace
um on the air traffic controller's
computer
evidently the little symbol that
represented that transponder from that
airplane disappeared
off the screens 37 seconds later
the entire airplane disappeared from the
secondary radar this was 1
21 am 39 minutes after the plane
had taken off now interestingly
the air traffic controller that was
working in kuala lumpur
was apparently um busy or
didn't notice it so they didn't notice
the plane disappearing off the radar
which seems a little
but you know what are you gonna do
people are gonna do like a shitty job
so he didn't notice that it uh he or she
i don't know
uh that this plane had disappeared off
the radar
now he finally did notice that he's like
hey where'd that [ __ ] plane go
now but at this point though he wasn't
alarmed because he's like well they were
heading for vietnamese airspace they
should have been in vietnamese airspace
by now
so now it's you know that's now heath on
their air
air traffic control and that's probably
just what happened so they didn't really
think anything
about it now meanwhile
the uh air traffic controllers in
vietnam airspace
they actually saw the plane come into
vietnamese airspace
and then disappear off the radar now
they got alarmed but i think that there
was some kind of miscommunication
because what they were supposed to do
the you know the the rule was
if an airplane had you know gets handed
off
from malaysian to vietnamese airspace
and
they didn't check in after five minutes
they were supposed
to call the air traffic controllers in
kuala lumpur and
be like hey what the [ __ ] this plane has
disappeared
um so they did seem to know that but
they didn't do it
until like 20 minutes later instead of
five minutes
so they like waited like too long i'm
not really entirely sure why
now to their credit they did actually
try to contact the airplane to see where
it had gone
uh but they were not successful in doing
that
so after they couldn't contact the
aircraft that was when
they contacted kuala lumpur and said hey
your plane just disappeared and this was
18 minutes
since they since the planet disappeared
from the radar
now at this point it just seems like i'm
not really sure what happened here
other than people just maybe not being
super competent at their jobs or they're
being miscommunication or you know just
general chaos and stupidity who knows
what's going on i don't really know
but apparently um i guess that kuala
lumpur their aeronautical rescue
coordination center should have been
notified
within the hour like that this plane had
disappeared
but for whatever reason no one notified
them
until four hours later
um as i said it doesn't seem like it was
anything sinister
it just seems like everyone was like
super disorganized and
miscommunicating and maybe somebody else
thought that person had done it and you
thought he had done it i don't know it
just kind of seemed like that
kind of situation so they actually
didn't
uh were not able to mobilize a rescue
effort
uh an emergency response rather until 6
30 in the morning
which is actually when the plane was
supposed to be landing in beijing
now it's interesting because i was
watching like i said i watched a bunch
of documentaries on this
and one guy that was talking was like we
were still
kind of hoping that the plane would just
that we had just lost track of the plane
and that it would land in beijing as
normal
um but obviously when that didn't happen
then everybody kind of started
uh flipping out so at this point
they start mobilizing
ships and airplanes to go
out and look for where this plane went
34 ships 28 aircraft from several
different countries from around the
region
and they started looking in the south
china sea because that's
where the plane was that's where they
lost uh
contact with it so they just assumed
they assumed
that right after the captain had checked
in there had been some kind of
catastrophic like it just
the plane just [ __ ] fell out of the
sky or something like that that's what
they were assuming
which is normally what you would assume
in this situation so they said well
that's we
where we need to go look like the last
place where the radar pinged
so that's where they started looking um
but they could not uh find it obviously
now for a long time you know for several
days afterward
they weren't really they weren't really
sure like what the [ __ ] was
going on like i said the first
assumption as it would be
was that as soon as it had disappeared
off radar as soon as they lost contact
with it that something catastrophic must
have happened
and that it just like fell in the ocean
or whatever so
that's kind of the assumption that they
were operating on
but a couple days later they get
um some records like from primary radar
and they got those from the air traffic
control computers
and they found out from this so this is
like a few days after the disappearance
they found out from radar [ __ ] from the
computers
that what it actually happened was that
the plane
very very shortly after it last checked
in with
the the malaysian air traffic
controllers and they said hey you know
call
ho chi minh and we're going to hand you
off now only a couple of seconds after
that happened
the plane took a very very sharp
turn to the southwest flew back
across uh malaysia
and then did like a banking turn around
uh penang like this which is an island
on the other side of there
and then it started flying northwest
up the strait of malacca and out towards
the andaman sea and then after that it
was out of radar range
now this whole maneuvering of it turning
like doing a hairpin turn
back across malaysia and then doing the
bank and then going back up
that took about an hour um
so the first thing that they thought was
that
okay so turning a plane that sharply
that's not autopilot autopilot can't do
that so they said a person
must have done that because you just
can't then autopilot can't do
a turn that chart so a person must have
been at this so the first thing they
thought
was hijacking right um which is the
first thing they would think of
so basically so okay
at this point as i said they kind of
know
where it headed but they don't know
where it ended up i mean they're pretty
sure because they have no idea where
this plane is now
that it crashed i mean obviously but
they don't know why they don't know why
it was
thrown off course so uh severely
they don't really know anything about
that
now at this point so
everybody around particularly australia
i think they were kind of like at the
forefront
forefront of um you know investigating
this it was a
kind of a joint effort uh the australian
authorities malaysian authorities
chinese authorities and also they had
the fbi and they're coming
later on and uh you know try to help out
and everything too
so the malaysian authorities though
were kind of um
not real forthcoming about what had
happened like i said i don't think it
was necessarily because
i know that the reason that that there
are so many conspiracy theories about
this
is that the malaysian government were
kind of secretive about it
but i think the reason for that might
have been that
you know as we'll find out later what
probably happened with this [ __ ]
was that they either didn't know what
caused it and they didn't want anybody
to know that they didn't know
or they thought it was like embarrassing
um you know what i mean and particularly
in the um
when the plane first vanished and then
they had problems of like
you know if it being like several hours
before
anybody uh kind of reported it and it
took like you know four or five hours
before anybody even got
like mobilized uh emergency services to
go out there
and that kind of made them look like
incompetent and i think that they didn't
really like that very much so i think
that was maybe more
the issue more than it being any kind of
like big cover-up or conspiracy theory
or anything like that
but they were actually very very uh
secretive
um however despite their secrecy uh
satellites and [ __ ] like that are kind
of global and everybody
can kind of you know they people can
kind of access those that
aren't uh that aren't enthrall to any
kind of malaysian officials right
so what they found out was that
after they so they had the radar
information that showed
that the plane had taken a hard turn to
the southwest and that had gone
particular and then they kind of lost
track of it
but apparently there is something
and i don't think well they probably
know now
but i don't think that airline pilots
knew at the time
but air airliners have a thing
where they send kind of like um
they link up to geostationary satellites
every half an hour with information
about where they're at
um you know what their altitude is i
think just like various
so they can keep track of like where the
planes are you know just in case
something bad happens
so i don't think at the time uh pilots
did not know about this system because
it just kind of happened automatically
so by going into that
information they found out there were
these
uh there was a satellite in the indian
ocean that was operated by
a vendor in london called inmarsat
and it showed that the plane
uh you know mh370 was still
flying for six hours after it
disappeared
off the radar because it kept pinging
that satellite so by following
those pings they could determine where
the plane had gone
and where its most likely location was
when it
inevitably ran out of fuel which is what
they think that it did um
in case you're wondering this little
thing with like pinging with the planes
with satellites that's called a
handshake which i thought was adorable
i don't know i don't know why i thought
that was so funny but yeah so i said the
pilots didn't know about it because it
just happens automatically
but that's how they knew uh where the
plane had ended up and the fact that
this plane didn't just like [ __ ]
crash into the ocean or disappear
it actually flew for a really really
long time
and probably flew until it ran out of
fuel it had
i believe it had enough fuel for
about seven hours and 45 minutes worth
of flight time
um because the flight from uh
kuala lumpur to beijing which it took
several like a couple times a day i
think was only
five hours five and a half hours
something like that
so it had like that fuel and like some
extra fuel but as far as i know it had
like seven hours and 45 minutes worth of
fuel in it
now so okay now there were also
there had also been two satellite phone
calls
made to the plane um neither of them
were answered now this was kind of after
that you know
people on the ground were trying to like
contact the plane and the phone did ring
like in the plane but nobody picked it
up
now so basically that what happened
was that from all the satellite
information and all that kind of crap
they were able to do
what they called like an ark so there's
this one arc
which is the last one before the plane
like disappeared
off of the satellites thing so they're
like okay well
in this area this is probably where the
plane went down right
now they have searched around that area
but it's a huge huge huge area and like
i said the weather is shitty and
everything like that but they're just
saying that's probably
where the rest of the plane is yeah
here's something else i wanted to say
just because a plane hits the drink at a
certain area
that doesn't mean where that plane is
because water is like the sky
it's hydrodynamic pieces of that [ __ ]
plane
if it's deep enough will kind of like
soar
through the water for miles and it'll be
scattered in different directions
everywhere
same thing happens when a ship sinks it
can sink on one area of the surface
but it doesn't hit the doesn't hit
doesn't hit the ground or the surface of
the ocean until miles away sometimes
and the thing about it too is that now
um with the technology we have nowadays
they can actually do drift analysis if
they know
you know the currents and everything and
the weather and [ __ ] like that on that
day which they do obviously
um they can come up with uh the most
likely place
like where the [ __ ] is like where it
went something like an aircraft that's
all aluminum it's weak
it's gonna hit the water and break apart
into a bunch of pieces
and then it's going to end up the wing
spar is going to break you're going to
have one wing you know probably
you'll probably have one wing go one way
another wing go another well a wing
just one wing on its own without the
fuselage of the plane
can probably travel quite far underneath
the water
because it'd kind of glide swirl around
do crazy [ __ ]
that thing might end up hitting it if
it's deep enough might end up hitting
the surface
surface or hitting the ground 10 miles
away from where it hit the surface of
the water
this is going to be a general area
sleazy b
says how can it disappear from radar but
still ping off a satellite
um it because it the transponder which
was the thing that was
you know making it come up on radar had
been turned off
finding that thing's gonna be hard it's
gonna be real hard to find that plane
what about the black box they have not
found the black box they haven't found
the they haven't found
the plane yeah they found little pieces
of what they think
are part of that plane are most likely
part of that plane
but the bulk of the plane has not been
found none of the bodies have been found
the black box has not been found
nothing i'll never find that plane i
mean they might but
that plane's in so many pieces it could
be
it's weird because i saw a couple
different documentaries about it
and we'll get to it but it depends on
how it hit the water like whether it was
in big because because some people think
like depending on one that it was
maybe in a in a few big pieces um
you know and they have some evidence to
back that up and then some people think
well maybe it was just like smash into a
zillion pieces
and i don't know we'll get into that but
like a wing can catch
it can it can hit the earth it can hit
the surface of the water in a wing tip
catch a wave or catch the water and send
that thing into a cartwheel and once
that happens it's just [ __ ]
disintegrated
i've seen it happen on video yeah
there's some like really really yeah
disturbing the water is nothing to [ __ ]
with at
high speeds it's like a solid yeah you
know
especially when you're dealing with
something like an aircraft it's just
aluminum and aluminum is light
and and most of that plant is hollow
it's fuel and passengers mostly it
doesn't weigh much for its size
easy to tear that apart like a kite
really
you know yeah tila said i just feel for
the relatives of these people
honestly it's like some of the
documentaries a couple of them were
australian
and so obviously they're going to focus
on you know the the few people that were
from australia or new zealand that were
on the plane and like their family
members and stuff
but they did actually show um
footage of the people that were waiting
to pick up the people
like in the beijing airport and they
were just like freaking out and i was
just like it was really really upsetting
like to watch it
because can you imagine it's just like
when the plane disappeared off the radar
um you know in the beijing airport like
the plane that oh now that flight says
delayed
right and then they had to like come and
tell everybody it's like hey
the plane's gone we don't know where
it's at can you [ __ ] imagine i can't
imagine
so yeah so from the uh the pings off the
geostationary
satellite they were able to determine
that once the plane
had turned uh done that sharp turn and
then kind of turned a little bit back
up that the airplane basically
flew very straight and very level for
a really long time basically until it
ran out of gas and it was also going
super fast it was going like 600 miles
an hour
which is uh faster than it would
normally get like on its flight right
now after six hours they think
um because what they could do like i
said from bouncing the [ __ ] off the
off the satellites they think that the
plane
went into a very very steep descent
um five times greater than a normal
descent rate
picked up all that speed and then uh
basically either
is like pretty much dived into the ocean
uh maybe some [ __ ] flew off the plane
before it hit
um it doesn't look like
the pilot tried to land it like normal
it looked like
someone was flying the [ __ ] into the
ocean on purpose
could have been terrorism that's the
first thing they thought but i
really i doubt it here's the thing the
more the more i like read about it the
more i doubt that
here's the thing about terrorism if
you're going to commit an act of
terrorism it's going to be high-profile
terrorism you want everybody to
know well that's one of the main reasons
i mean there's other reasons too but
right you don't want to do a terroristic
act and then it
be mistaken for something else you got
to make it a
signature move so if it was a terrorist
act you probably would have radioed in
and set it over the radio i'm [ __ ]
down the plane because you did this and
that
[ __ ] you all [ __ ] you know and
then
that did it you don't want there to be
any gray area or anything you know i
mean so
probably not terrorism yeah well and
like i said that was the first thing you
would think you would think hijacking
but once more information started to
come in they're like yeah probably not
but like for example that exact reason
well
there's other reasons too but you were
going to hijack a plane why would you
and you were going to crash it into the
ground why do that in the middle of
nowhere in the ocean you want to do that
near the airport see it yeah
there you go you want to do that late in
its flight and
hit a target in the city near the
yeah now airport just wasting your time
sandra says i think the passengers
didn't know what happened and i'm sure
jenny will explain why later yes i will
that's the only good thing that's what i
was thinking too it's like i i kind of
hope that it happened
i mean i wish it hadn't happened at all
obviously because it's horrifying
but if it happened the way they think
that it happened i'm just kind of glad
that it happened like that because i
don't think the passengers knew what was
going on
you know what i mean so i'm just saying
so
uh so about a week after uh the plane
disappeared
the um the wall street journal published
uh a report about these satellite
transmissions saying hey what the hell
this plane disappeared off radar which
means somebody turned the transponder
off and
turned off and like started going off
course and according to the satellite
data
was kind of flying like for a really
really long time
into the middle of the indian ocean at
which point probably
it dived into the ocean like or it ran
out of gas one of the other two things
so uh the malaysian officials were kind
of like
didn't want to admit this at first
because like i said they were very cagey
i don't think it was anything to do
because i know some people
later on like had conspiracy theories
like oh they're covering up this that
and the other thing
like oh they shot the plane down or they
did the sound the other thing i don't
think that's the case
i just think they whiffed it and they
didn't want to look bad
so they were just um yeah uh yeah that's
that's what happened
okay yeah so it was that kind of thing i
think they were just like embarrassed
because they'd [ __ ] it up
and they didn't want everybody to
thinking that they thinking they were
idiots they didn't know how to do [ __ ]
i don't know that's just my theory but
i'm just saying but they finally did say
yes that's that's what happened so
that's kind of what we're uh
we're going with now you know because
everybody
the shitty thing about this though is
that
the searches even though it seems like
shortly after the plane disappeared they
knew
that from the data like from the
satellites and from i think there was
even a military radar that had picked
the plane up briefly
they knew that the plane had
deliberately flown off course
and they pretty much knew where it was
going or at least in the general
direction
but they still let everybody
spend millions and millions of dollars
searching in the south china sea where
they knew that plane was not
because they knew that that's not where
it had gone it had gone like six
hours away from that so
that was pretty shitty that they just
like kind of let all these planes and
ships and stuff and like i said spend
all these man hours and all this money
looking in the south china sea when they
knew that the plane wasn't
in there so i thought that was pretty
shitty because they did
seem like they knew enough information
to at least be like hey you're looking
in the wrong place
you know what i mean so i mean
and i'm not gonna i know that it's
really really difficult i mean
as i said the ocean is a big [ __ ]
thing right
and it's just like um one example they
like to give
remember like air france uh 447 which
went down in 2009
and that was going from uh rio to paris
and they knew pretty much exactly where
that plane went down and it still took
them two years to find that [ __ ] like
even with all the technology and
everything that they had
so even if you know where you're looking
it's still really difficult
to find because all you can do is work
on probabilities and so that's why they
have all of these computer
models that it's just kind of like well
you know according to the current
and according to how fast the plane was
going and what angle hit the water and
blah blah
and it's just they have all these
factors that they have to put but it's
only probabilities
it might not be there you know what i
mean it's just kind of like oh this is
the most likely place but that doesn't
mean that's where it is
so you know that's kind of shitty so
they start looking uh so they're doing
all the surface water when they finally
figured out hey maybe the plane's over
here in like in the south indian ocean
and
instead of over here we thought it might
have been like along the initial flight
path where it was supposed to be going
after that search didn't yield anything
like seriously they found
nothing they didn't find like a single
[ __ ] it's like there's some satellite
photos and stuff where it's just kind of
like oh maybe this is a thing and say
but every single thing they investigated
was nothing
so um you know they they searched for
like two or three months like just in
the surface waters and nothing came up
they didn't find a single [ __ ] stitch
of that plane
now there were also a couple of like red
herrings because everybody got super
excited because at one point
they picked up these two like very faint
kind of pings that sounded like they
might be from like the black box or
whatever the
you know the cabin uh what do they call
it the cabin
voice recorder whatever and uh so they
were like oh we found it we found it but
then when they went to investigate what
i forgot my drink
yeah but then when they went to
investigate it there was nothing there
it was just kind of like a false alarm
so everybody was getting really really
bummed and really frustrated
about this so a while goes by it's kind
of like
i don't think i don't remember if it was
like quite a year but i think was like
14 months i want to say
so after 14 months there's this dude and
his name is blaine gibson
and i think he's american he's like a
lawyer but he kind of fancies himself
and i don't mean this to sound
derogatory but he kind of fancies
himself like an indiana jones type dude
um he has a thing where he wants to go
to like every country in the world and
he's like an adventurer and stuff so he
was really interested in this uh in the
disappearance of this plane
and he kind of looked into it and he
said you know what um
those p some pieces of this plane like
probably washed up somewhere
and i'm gonna figure out where that [ __ ]
is so he actually
did kind of look into it i think he
ended up going to like mozambique and
some places like that
and indeed him and a couple other people
did actually find some debris
that they are 99 sure came from that
[ __ ] airplane
now the first one that they found it was
this uh this piece of a plane
it was a what they call like a flapper
on it's that thing that's like on the
wing that goes up and down like when
you're
you know i mean like that yeah it's like
a flapper yeah yeah yeah it's one of
those
and uh they found one of those and um
basically it like washed up on a beach
in
july 2015 um in
reunion reunion i guess which is a
french-owned island it's in the western
indian ocean
now this was actually where they found
this
piece of the plane 2 200 nautical miles
west
of where they had been looking
underwater so again
you know it's it was far away from what
they were they were looking at first
so at this point um this guy gibson
and some other investigators and stuff
started finding like little
pieces of the plane now it's kind of
like
they're not some of the stuff they're
like
almost like 99 sure that it came from
that i think there's like three pieces
they're like 99 sure this came from that
plane the other ones they're like this
probably came for the plane but we can't
like say
completely because there's a lot of
boeing 777s um
but you know so they're pretty sure that
they found
20 30 pieces of it that have washed up
on various beaches
over the ensuing years so as i said july
2015 was the first piece
and then by october of 2017 they had
found about 20 pieces of debris
that they think came from this plane all
along beaches along the western indian
ocean
so uh they also found later this is like
super creepy
they they haven't found any bodies yet
as far as i'm aware
but they have found um stuff that they
think
like belong to some of the people on the
plane like backpacks and purses and
stuff
like just every now and then they find
it and it's like that's like super
creepy
but um you know like i said i don't know
if they can entirely
because i mean i guess the family could
like identify hey that's you know
my mom's purse or whatever um you know
so they can find that because i don't
think there was anything in the purse
that they found or the backpack
i think it was empty because it had been
in the water for sure what are you doing
pokey she came out and pulled on chair
what you want to go somewhere
where you want to go poke can you go
outside no it's too it's too
bright like this it's too like hot out i
would think
it's only 7 10. she's trying to get me
to do something
i'm trying to get me to do some
yeah she's been like real uh
attention seeking today
she came up earlier i was trying to
watch a movie on my on my other laptop
over there
and she kept coming up and like sitting
on it so finally i had to move this
laptop like over here in my lap and then
she just like went and fell asleep on
the desk
snoring and stuff while i was like
watching a movie
but yeah so so the fact that the plane
itself and none of the bodies have been
found means that
you know obviously everybody's going to
come up with some crazy ass
uh conspiracy theories which
i don't know like i said there's a lot
of other evidence like from the
you know satellites and everything like
that but they know where the plane went
to
just the fact that they haven't found it
yet and they're not entirely sure
you know like i said the ocean's a big
place and as i mentioned earlier
it could have been that it just ran out
of fuel
uh if it just ran out of fuel and kind
of like
glided i guess or go went into a death
spiral or whatever
um that would be much different than if
somebody deliberately
dove it into the ocean so they're still
trying to like decide
which of those scenarios was the case oh
hey look pookie's on the show
pookie's on the show now so let's talk
about some of these
uh weirdos that are out there like
thinking that they know what happened to
this [ __ ]
so there's this one woman uh she's
a british lady and she has a blog
and her name is saucy sailorus because
of course it is
she's also a tarot reader so take that
with uh
whatever you want to take it with now
she claimed
that she was on vacation in southern
asia
with her husband and they were on a
sailboat
and she says that on the night the
flight disappeared
they were in that same area
and she said she saw what looked like a
cruise missile coming at her
and then she saw that it was actually an
airplane
and that it was uh with the cockpit all
lit up and then it had like a weird
orange glow about it like it was going
super fast and it was like had all this
smoke behind it
and she said that at the time she
thought that it was on a suicide mission
against a chinese naval fleet which was
out at sea
okay now she claimed
again allegedly that oh i didn't even
know
about that flight disappearing until
like a day or two later and then i put
the two things together in my head and
so that she like blogged about it
but i think it turned out later that
it's like she wasn't even in the part of
the ocean where the plane disappeared so
um she maybe just like saw some
crazy [ __ ] and like or just made it up i
don't make that [ __ ] up allegedly yeah
so i just made that [ __ ] up there's
another dude
who's australian and this is uh this is
your uh
guy that's trying to cash in on [ __ ] he
says
that he knows where the plane is he says
he found it
on google earth and it's intact
which is doubtful because they found
some pieces of it um
and that it's in shallow waters but he
says
i'm not gonna tell you [ __ ] where it
is until you crowdfund my expedition on
kickstarter
so he's trying to crowdfund him can you
[ __ ] imagine
if one of my relatives if one of my
relatives had been killed in that
in that plane crash i would
pay to fly to that dude's house and
punch him right in the [ __ ]
griff oh i know where the plane is i can
see it on google earth
no you don't and it's all in one piece
it definitely isn't because like i said
they found some pieces of it
so i suspect that thing disintegrated on
impact it cartwheeled
i think probably yes i could yeah um you
know depending it's a
you know i it just it crashed for sure
whether
it crashed you know deliberately or he
just ran out of gas
we'll get into that in a little bit now
there's also been and this was actually
one
this is actually a conspiracy theory
i've heard too that um
oh the plane's actually intact in the
cambodian jungle
uh or in a river in indonesia and like
all the people are still alive
that's another thing and it's just been
like covered up
which seems far-fetched um but i have
heard that one before
as i said some people said it flew into
a time warp uh you know
30 years from now it'll land somewhere
which is [ __ ] up
or got sucked into a black hole uh you
know kidnapped by aliens i've heard that
one too
um there's also a conspiracy theory that
the plane was going to attack
uh the american military base on diego
garcia but then it got shot down why
they would do
the passenger plane i don't really know
um some people said there's a conspiracy
theory going around
that the captain uh was found alive in a
taiwanese hospital and had amnesia
um that was one that kind of went around
asia uh
you know and i think i've kind of heard
that one over here as well
um that one you know
take this i was reading an article in
the atlantic there's a really good
article in the atlantic about this
and uh they said well the that story
actually came from a website that also
reported that there had been
like an american tourist and two sherpas
who were raped by a yeti
so you know that's just kind of like
that's the kind of [ __ ] that we're
dealing with here
now here's another this is another
common one that i've seen a lot of times
too
is that there's some conspiracy
theorists that
think that the russians
stole the airplane in order to create a
distraction
from uh crimea being annexed which was
going on at that time
but but you know everybody's saying and
they said oh well the plane actually was
flown to kazakhstan
which is where it would have gone if it
had turned north but they but the
satellites had turned south
so but the but this guy and like people
that believe this
conspiracy theory think that oh all the
data was faked
which again far-fetched that would be
super super hard to do
come on like all the [ __ ] from all
these different satellites and all these
different that don't like even cooperate
with each other [ __ ] off
um there's people i don't know man
conspiracy theorists make me so mad
it's just kind of like they don't even
like think about the [ __ ] they say
they just like this they just like the
story that's grifting
i mean they just like the story i guess
yeah
so the fourth showdown says clearly the
langeliers were responsible yeah
might as well have been i mean you know
holy [ __ ]
so as stupid as what tell you what man
drinking this grape juice based drink
yeah it makes you want to get some that
pinnacle [ __ ] peanut butter vodka
did they even have that in the liquor
store i didn't notice no you didn't have
a liquor store but the pinnacle makes it
yeah well pinnacle makes like all the
flavors
they probably make [ __ ] pickled hairs
we had that we had that before remember
yeah had that [ __ ] at the [ __ ] bar
yeah it was [ __ ]
pinnacle peanut butter on the rocks with
[ __ ] grape juices peanut butter jelly
sandwich that [ __ ] was so good
[ __ ] mega says never trust sandra
sandra if you can get [ __ ] pinnacle
peanut butter vodka go ahead and do it
man it's cheap here
probably expensive in germany
man that shit's good it is yeah yeah
well you can do a lot with it you know
yeah the whipped cream is better but
more versatile but i was sitting here
drinking this going man i want a peanut
butter jelly
i like the whipped cream but it gets a
little sweet after a while you got to
know what to mix it with
yeah you got to do it even if you make
it with good [ __ ] it's like yeah after
like
two or three drinks it's like yeah it
just gets too sickly
so yeah so as stupid as a lot of these
[ __ ] theories are
um you know no all of that [ __ ]
satellite thing wasn't
faked or [ __ ] or spoofed i think that's
what they call it's the spoofs and area
that's what they call it
where yeah that was all just like like
intentionally planted
like to make it look like the plane went
somewhere else like to throw them off
the trail
oh that's well thank you very much
nicodemus he said
thank you nicodemus
oh my goodness then sandra jumps in man
i bet if you can make a creamy peanut
butter liqueur yourself like coffee
liqueur baileys
oh yeah something like that's probably
out there it's gotta be
i even like that peanut butter whiskey
to be honest with you germany should be
easy to order anything from anywhere
online man but
i would recommend the pinnacle which is
cheap it's an inexpensive vodka get a
big bottle of that pinnacle
it tastes [ __ ] great pinnacle peanut
butter
yeah put it on the rocks throw some damn
[ __ ]
grape juice on it maybe salt around the
rim
oh man well yeah that's always good
yeah yeah yeah honestly i like that
peanut butter peanut butter vodka is
good with
coke yeah and with a lot like kosher
salt around the rim as well yeah that's
good too it tastes like a oh henry bar
or like a payday like a payday bar which
is a candy bar here super peanut
yeah super peanut peanut and [ __ ]
kind of caramel
taste good sleazy b says tam my brother
made cinnamon flavored moonshine once
what did it say did it taste like
fireball because well
i love cinnamon but i really don't
really fireball would sell well
in germany fireball just gives me
heartburn like instant heartburn
fireball is americans version the
[ __ ] with the
jagermeister or goldschmidt that shit's
yeah that's like gold yeah the american
gold slugger
i've had a shot of it every now and then
if somebody buys me one i'm not paying
for that [ __ ] myself i like goldschlager
i know you do
yeah they mix it with other things in
shots
like i said anything anything like that
i love
cinnamon like in its natural form but
anything
cinnamon flavored like cinnamon liqueurs
like red hots anything like that just
gives me instant heartburn
i don't just like i don't know why but
it does which sucks i love cinnamon
toast though
just saying [ __ ] name this says hey
time on pcs into korea any tips
go check out [ __ ] hooker hill it's
not as good as it was back in my day but
i don't know where you're going to be
deployed i mean you got to give me the
right camp you tell me what camp it was
and my information is old man
i was there in the early 90s i mean
my camp is now which is camp greaves is
across the [ __ ] river
mgm river is now like
a a uh it's part of a tour
my my camp is a [ __ ] what do you call
it a [ __ ]
tourist attraction it's a tourist
attraction historical
[ __ ] monument that's where i was
right there on the dmz
uh so it's it's not it's it's not like
it was
you know um
i liked it big-ass but big-ass [ __ ]
spiders
but it was cold man cold in the winter
we got big-ass spiders
oh no they were bigger over there they
were their asses on them things were the
size of a [ __ ] ping-pong ball yeah
i've seen ones like that
hanging from webs all the time walking
through them and fighting them and
that's all right
if there were no spiders with this world
would be just
be ass deep in mosquitoes yeah just
saying
spiders are your friends no squish them
but yeah so uh all right so where was i
so basically what they do know from all
of the information they have where this
[ __ ] plane went
they know for sure that the route that
it took
was deliberate so
the question then becomes was this
terrorist like was it a hijacker or
was it a member of the flight crew
going rogue so because basically those
are the only two things because like i
said the turn that it took
uh you know shortly after it vanished
from radar they said there's no way that
a person had to do that there was there
was no way that the autopilot did it or
it wasn't
malfunction the weather was good there
wasn't anything else conceivable that
could have happened
uh that would have caused that to happen
thank you zach hey y'all what's up
tom i think your life story would make
an awesome movie directed by myself
of course you couldn't make this movie
until after i died though that's the
problem
um then a [ __ ] sleazy b
is talking about moonshine he's fighting
with other people that don't know what
moonshine is from other countries this
is part of american culture
moonshine uh is a v
almost damn near pure alcohol and it's
made out of corn
usually made out of corn um same thing
was in brazil called kashasa
it's like 180 190 proof strong alcohol
not much flavor it's distilled it's just
a way of getting [ __ ] drunk
uh but moonshine has become an art uh
recently
back in the prohibition era of the
united states moonshine was uh
just something it was quick and dirty it
was just something to [ __ ] give to
people
you can mix it with punch and other
drinks and make it alcoholic and
you would get [ __ ] [ __ ] up on it it
was very strong
but nowadays you get craft moonshine
some of it's even flavored like well
yeah everybody's super into like making
their beer and wine and all that kind of
stuff nowadays
atf or barrel of alcohol tobacco and
firearms laxed up a lot on making your
own
liquor you can make your own i think you
just limit to how much you make and you
can't sell it
that's that's the thing but you can make
your own alcohol at home
in in the united states i just don't
think you can sell it
yeah but you can give it away you can
give
yeah but they got people making wine or
beer at home and you can make all that
you can distill alcohol at home you can
do whatever you want
yeah i mean i don't know if like state
laws are different but i don't think any
i don't think any state has a they don't
care about
like i said as long as you're not like
starting your own [ __ ] liquor comes
like without a license
yeah you can't sell it right um but no
they got
beer kits and wine kits and distillery
kits and everything you can buy online
here in the united states and just make
your own brew
zach says also if there was a movie
about you who would play you
and your dad can any actor reproduce his
voice all right first of all
my dad's being played a miniature lee
majors
oh my god that would be good yeah lee
majors was in
uh ash vs evil dead yeah he played
played bruce campbell's death yeah yeah
my dad would be lee majors
he doesn't look like that but it's that
same mentality
um i would be played by
uh tom cruise anything
because tom yeah of course why do you
think that
you don't look anything like tom cruise
who would play me then we're about the
same age
um i don't know i'd have to like look at
i'm not roll up on my actors i don't
really
know it depends on what age that the
person has to play me you know well
somebody has to play you at like all
ages because it's your life story
well then who's going to play baby tom
the kid that played the
damien and the omen but he's like old
man now
because that's what you look like
i know that's what i'm saying it was
maybe like they need to find another kid
that looks like that right
yeah like nowadays that's how i looked i
looked exactly like that
yeah somebody said who would play me i
have no idea yeah
i've thought about that like lots of
times but i don't know i can't think of
like any act so i'd be
really [ __ ] if like somebody asked me
that like on a live show or something oh
like right now
um you know what i mean if i was ever
like real famous and somebody asked me
that i'd be like
brad jones says tom and jen look into dr
joseph lange
oh he's trying to tell me that like the
ci or somebody like
crashed the plane like just to kill that
one person yeah i doubt it i i don't
think that's what happened
well honestly like i said i'm i'm
getting into like what i think happened
the cia can the cia or anybody can kill
anybody a lot easier than that
yeah it's very easy to kill somebody
this is another thing and i've come up
with
i've come up um on this a couple of
times
in my true crime books like some of the
cases that i've written about
where there were these weird cases of
like people dying in like weird
mysterious ways or whatever
and you know some people like oh well
they were
you know friends with a government
official or something so it was like the
cia bumped them off
and i was kind of thinking you know if
the cia was going to bump you off they
would just do it and it would totally
look like an accident like nobody would
even suspect
i mean there wouldn't even be enough to
like suspect that it wasn't an accident
like because they're not that
incompetent no if you go through the
idea of like killing 230 odd people
attract too much attention just i mean
that really seems
dumb when why i mean you should just be
like run them over with the [ __ ] car
or something it's just like jesus it's a
lot easier than that
you could have like a team of three or
four people i'm gonna tell you how it's
done
take three or four people and you have
to look at the target and see how they
live
if they live in a building or go to
anywhere high the idea is to throw them
off that building
that's the one thing you want to do if
they don't work or live anywhere around
a building
you abduct them you grab them handcuff
them you put them in a trunk
you take them out somewhere to a thing
and you pop them in this
side of the head with a pistol leave the
pistol there
dump a [ __ ] suicide note and the
suicide note doesn't even really even
have to be cons
convincing you don't even need the
suicide note
and if it's the cia or these other it if
it's a cia or another
important agency that did this there's a
motive for the police and the agencies
to not investigate or to just close it
saying
suicide yeah yeah
the reason why the person was killed is
that there was a motive
to kill the person so therefore suicide
i yeah i kind of feel like yeah the the
a lot of
homicide depends a lot upon the target
and if it's pre-planned and it's done in
a [ __ ] team
it's much easier to do if it's a bad
person
or a person that the government wants
gone there's not going to be a [ __ ]
invest a stringent investigation if it's
the worst person to kill
and the hardest one would be a teenage
white girl
there's going to be an investigation
okay
just the way it is yeah is this a serial
killer
or whatever if it's somebody in their
40s or 30s and they're [ __ ] not like
old or they're not white there are there
no
no no no that's not what it is it's if
they're on the wrong
side of some powerful person inside the
government
there's not going to be an investigation
a bat a lawyer that you don't like who's
[ __ ] suing you
or something like that just look at who
just look at the body counts
and it's not just the united states it's
other countries too same thing was going
on in iraq and other third world
countries
you go up against powerful people they
kill you there's no investigation
not a real investigation yeah yeah i
mean i kind of feel like
what happened here was
i don't think it was anything to do with
terrorism i don't think it was anything
to do with it was just like a very very
strange
uh situation so you're saying the cia
down the plane to kill one person
nah if they wanted that person dead they
would have killed that particular person
and you would have never noticed you
would have never noticed
they're not like i said they they
they're good at that
[ __ ] yeah they're very good kind of one
of their things
and i'm not saying that they don't
totally do that because they do
yeah but they're a lot better at it than
hey let's kill like 230 something in
like one of the biggest
uh and this was actually the most
expensive like air like search for like
a
lost aircraft yeah in history so
i don't really think they would go this
splashy
no they come in if you if you're in a
building
they come in with some kind of badges or
some kind of story to talk to you three
or four of them
and uh they're having a good time they
might be approaching you as friends they
open a damn window
three of them grab you four of them grab
you one on your channel
they throw you out the [ __ ] window
and leave the window open and they just
leave
there's cameras now it's uh it's harder
to do that but that's the way it was
and even in the cia manual they talked
about that
yeah so i always kind of
i mean i'm not like giving anybody
recommendations or anything but i always
thought like the best thing to do was
like befriend the person
and then hey let's go on a hike well
yeah up in the mountains and then just
go
dude well that's the push them off and
then be like oh no
he fell off the mountain intelligence
agencies
use mobsters use organized criminals and
[ __ ] like that to do what it is that
they do
and they use the same tactics and if you
read
true stories of how the italian mafia
who they were really good
okay how they killed people
it's just like jenny talked about they
come at you as friends
they send friends people that you know
to you
and you're relaxed you don't even know
it's coming
and they kill you and they're trying to
keep you from testifying that's what it
is
you know something you did something a
lot they're afraid you're gonna grow the
cops
you don't even know the shit's you don't
you know you think
hey man i heard they're coming for you
we gotta get you out of here man they're
gonna kill you
yeah yeah get me out of here those are
the [ __ ] that are gonna kill
you
well that's what i would do right yeah
i'm your friend everything you're safe
with me yeah right right
right exactly i mean that's the oldest
tricks in the book
sure and you know you can see why people
fall for it though because it's like
why would you think your friends would
do it yeah but that's usually who does
it
yeah well and they usually don't feel
good about it it's just that they don't
want to go to jail
yeah you know it's just part of that
business
and you shouldn't have got into that
business if you didn't know it would go
that way i mean like you kind of knew
what you were you knew what you were
getting into this thing
right like yeah you might have to like
bump off your friends every now and then
you're right
right kind of a bummer but that's it's
they see the self-defense you gotta go
because
they got you and we're next and
well yeah and they'll probably sell it
to you as like oh well a lot of people
are going to go to jail or get killed
right right right we don't do this one
thing yeah we got to get rid of this guy
yeah it's going to be that good fellas
good fellows talked about that that
other one you know a lot of the old
classic gangster movies are spot-on
that's exactly how they do it and that's
how the cia does it
or when they did do it they don't do it
they'll have [ __ ]
somebody like ms-13 do it for them well
i mean it's always
better not to get your hands here you
need to have like a couple things
like a remover too yeah thank you victor
just got here is this the chupacabra
episode just kidding
yeah it's a chupacabra you know what i
don't think we've ever done an episode
on the chupacabra now that i'm thinking
about it
never did one uh it wouldn't let
wouldn't be that it probably wouldn't be
that long it would be that long
it's a mangy dog thing yeah it's a dog
because you know how i do yeah but uh
yeah that's the whole that's what the
whole thing would be
all right so okay so at this point all
they know
they know that the [ __ ] was deliberate
so like i said
knowing that it's deliberate because
they know it wasn't mechanical failure
it wasn't anything like that
so they said so the two possibilities
are either
somebody uh you know breached the
cockpit
and did all this [ __ ] on the plane or a
member of the crew
went rogue and committed essentially
murder suicide because
like i said there were 230 odd people on
this plane
and it seems like it was brought down on
purpose
so there were some theories too that
um another conspiracy theory was that
somebody had
controlled it remotely like from the
ground
but as far as anyone is aware that's
that technology doesn't really exist to
any great degree so that's not really
you know what i mean and boeing had been
like yeah well like we were working on
something kind of like that but nobody
could do that like right now
so that's probably not something that
could be done
so at this point they know that
something happened in the cockpit
uh either the captain and or
the first officer went rogue and decided
hey i'm gonna kill everybody
on this plane and myself or somebody
took over the cockpit
from somewhere else and this happened
sometime between
uh in the 20 minutes between 101 a.m
that was when the airplane went up to
its uh
35 000 feet uh altitude uh to 1 21
am and that's when it disappeared from
the secondary radar
now at this point they know that there
was nothing
uh mechanically wrong with the plane uh
at least as far as they could determine
because
yeah same thing yeah because
during that time period you know every
30 minutes
uh there's a satellite update which goes
to
the airline's maintenance department and
it says how much fuel is left in the
plane
what altitude they're at what speed
they're at where they're at
like you know the geographic position it
you know relays all that information
every half an hour
and nothing appeared to be a miss you
know so they weren't there were no
mechanical failures as
you know they weren't out of fuel
nothing like that so it was nothing
malfunctioning uh at that time period
but
something nevertheless happened within
this 20 minute time period
so what they're thinking
uh because of what we said earlier like
i said the first thing they thought of
was terrorists like somebody had
breached the cockpit
and for whatever reason turned off the
transponders turned off all the
communications and then just flew the
plane
to the middle of the indian ocean for
whatever reason
and then crashed it uh not really sure
but for one thing um
this particular aircraft uh you know and
most other aircrafts of this
uh kind have not only
these big reinforced doors but they also
have like cameras like outside
so you can see if somebody's coming into
the cockpit like you can see who that is
like the pilot and the co-pilot can see
it
so um if somebody had tried to breach
the cockpit
you would think that there would have
been some kind of like distress signal
like you know because they would have
had ample time like the the pilot or the
co-pilot
would have had ample time because it's
just like a little button and they'd be
like hey
mayday like somebody's trying to get in
this [ __ ] um you know
some people said well maybe uh maybe it
was terrorists maybe there were
stowaways like maybe they kind of like
you know were in the cargo hold and they
like came in through a [ __ ]
uh you know hatch in the floor or
whatever which
possible but again unlikely um
it just seems like it would have been
too difficult
and it by the time that they would have
done that
then if that was indeed the case then
either the pilot or the co-pilot would
have had ample time again
to contact somebody with a mayday uh
you know kind of alert and that didn't
happen the fact that
the pilot gave a message
saying basically good night this is this
plane and then
just went off the radar like that seems
to me
to suggest that
it was probably this is probably a case
of
the pilot going
rogue not in a terrorist kind of way
in a murder-suicide kind of way and i
kind of feel like that's
probably what that's what most of the
evidence to me points to
i don't think anybody else got on this
plane i don't think
anybody got into the cockpit um that
doesn't
really seem to be the case and i just
don't see
any other way and i don't you know i i
hate to like
cast aspersions on a dude that's dead
now
um you know because you know his
family's still around and stuff but
i kind of feel like maybe this dude the
pilot
he just decided i'm gonna kill myself
and i'm gonna take everybody out with me
and i kind of feel like that's what he
did so and
that's what most experts kind of think
happened too because there's really no
other
there really doesn't seem to be any
other one once you rule out terrorism
because they know for sure that
this all was done on purpose once you
rule out terrorism and they're pretty
sure that that wasn't
the case because like i said not only
would it have been too difficult there
were no distress calls blah blah blah
but no one has ever taken um you know no
one's ever taken credit
for doing it which is kind of the whole
point of terrorism killing yourself and
going rogue isn't terrorism it's a big
difference
well no that's what that's what i'm
saying i don't i don't think this is
earlier on in another show
and this is something that happens a lot
with soldiers and happy soldiers in
every [ __ ] war it's a lot easier to
die in a group than it is alone
could be that a person who wanted to
kill themselves maybe could only muster
up the courage if they were
weren't alone when they did it there's a
possibility and the thing about this guy
is that
i kind of feel like
i don't want to die but if you guys all
come with me it's a lot easier
ain't that some [ __ ] which is [ __ ] up
but there might be a certain kind of
psychology that's like that well and
this isn't the first time that that's
happened either with an airplane
pilot there were um
german infantry units freezing to death
outside of stalingrad in world war ii
and they would [ __ ] this was they
weren't getting supplies
they were [ __ ] cut off they were
ordered to take stalingrad there was no
way to get out of there
they were just dying one by one slowly
from [ __ ]
cold lack of supplies and enemy action
they found entire the russians
after the [ __ ] battle found entire
[ __ ] platoons
of german soldiers had committed suicide
in formation so that means they stood
there in a platoon formation
and all on all at once on a certain
count blew their own heads off
that's amazing when you think about it
but like you said it's
actually easier to do in a group i can
oh i can totally see that than to do
because you know other people are going
you're all your friends are all going
with you yeah and it's kind of like the
peer pressure and you're not alone
you so mass suffering is a lot easier to
deal with than
solo suffering so it could be that the
pilot was in that mindset
yeah well i mean no
no one knows because the dude's dead but
possibility
i kind of feel like
as i said all the evidence points to
this being done
deliberately and the fact
that it probably was not terrorists
uh as in there wasn't a third party that
got into the cockpit there wasn't
you know nobody took uh you know credit
for it or anything like that
leads me to believe that it was either
the pilot or the first officer
that decided i'm gonna kill myself and
i'm gonna take this whole
plane with me and they just found this
really like creepy weird
way to do it and because i really don't
i don't see any other way that it could
have gone so okay so let's get into
what they think might have happened so
basically what they think happened from
the time that the plane
went off the secondary radar uh which
was the one that was
transponder that you know transponder
dependent
um they think at this point
if it was indeed the pilot zahari
who was the one that was orchestrating
this whole thing
um then it's likely that
the first officer had either been locked
out of the cockpit
as in hey why don't you go get me some
from the cabin and then he leaves and
then he locks him out
or he had overpowered him i think the
first thing is probably more likely
because it's easier um just be easier
for the captain to be like hey
go get me a cup of coffee or go do
something and when he leaves the cockpit
the captain
locks him out and uh so i think he might
have been the only person
in there uh so at this point
there were uh the autopilot was switched
off
um they know that the you know because
the turn that the airplane made to the
southwest was like a hairpin
turn honestly and they said uh autopilot
couldn't do that that had to be manually
controlled
so they know that somebody was flying
the plane
now at this point they think that
whoever was flying the plane
deliberately depressurized it
and um shut down the electrical
system uh so they're not really sure why
that is they know
probably to keep people from getting in
the cockpit well no they know probably
why you
depressurized it because there's a point
too
and this is a little bit disputed but
not that disputed the plane was uh like
i said was cruising at 35 000 feet
uh the plane was depressurized on
purpose because there's like a button
that you have to push like the captain
can push it
they said usually that's there for like
if there's a fire in the cabin for
example
um and you know they have to deprive it
of oxygen
so they'll push that but normally you
wouldn't
but somebody did and then
allegedly uh the plane
made a very rapid ascent to about 40
000 feet which was about its uh limit
they speculate that the captain
not only turned like not only
depressurized the cabin
but also flew it upward really quick
because that would make
uh the oxygen come out of the cabin
quicker
which would kill everyone in the cabin
because i don't know if you guys know
but the the oxygen masks that come down
there's only about 15 minutes worth of
oxygen in those because it's usually
just kind of like hey
words it's just enough oxygen to get
through like whatever
problem that you're having um in the
cabin
they have oxygen masks also but there's
several hours of oxygen in there
obviously in case there's an emergency
but
so if you're in the cabin what likely
would have happened
they said and this is what sandra was
saying earlier about maybe the
passengers didn't know
was that what would have happened they
wouldn't really have noticed anything
necessarily
maybe the plane that was with some
turbulence or whatever and then the
oxygen masks would have come down
and they would have put them on but
um after a time especially if he flew
upward very quickly which would make the
oxygen leave the cabin
faster um everybody in the cabin
would have um basically had the mask on
and then they would have just
uh gone kind of loopy and then they
would have just gone to sleep
and then they would have suffocated so
they're kind of thinking that the pilot
if this was a suicide mission which is
it indeed seems to be
that he felt bad and he didn't want the
he didn't seem to want the passengers to
be afraid
that he was like gonna crash the [ __ ]
and so
he basically depressurized the cabin
and flew upward really quick and just
made everybody go unconscious and then
they died from suffocation without
really knowing what happened to them
so he's basically flying around for five
or six hours with a plane full of dead
people
damn is that [ __ ] creepy yeah that
creeped me out so much
but there's i mean they're not certain
but they're pretty sure like all the
evidence points to
that being probably what happened so
he it's so weird like why like if he
wanted to kill himself like don't
i mean this is just like a pro tip you
want to like kill yourself just [ __ ]
do it like you don't have to take other
people with you nobody that
that's not what he thought i mean those
people were all innocent people there
was like kids on that plane
it's just kind of like what the [ __ ] man
holy [ __ ]
so it's just yeah but they think that's
what happened i mean at least
he made it so that they didn't suffer i
guess but it's just kind of like
those people are just going on vacation
and [ __ ] man it's like or they were
going back home it's like why
they didn't have anything to do with you
maybe he thought that was would be less
scary
to him well yeah i'm sure it was i mean
because like the [ __ ] that happened
later was certainly scary yeah
but that's what he was thinking but yeah
so
i don't know if he did it because i mean
allegedly i said nobody knows
i don't know if he did it because he
just thought oh well
they'll die and it'll be fine or if he
just didn't want anybody [ __ ] with
his [ __ ]
because if he decided oh i'm gonna go
rogue and i'm gonna fly over here and
like some of the passengers would like
flip out and be like hey the [ __ ] what
are you what are you doing and would
like try to like be
like start getting unruly and [ __ ] um so
maybe he just wanted to like you want to
be alone want to knock him off
yeah because that's why they think that
he like he probably locked the
first officer out of the cockpit as well
we're halfway through did you want to
run your uh program
yeah because probably i should go to the
bathroom too um now
do you know how to the the commercial is
about a minute long
which one is it it's this one strange
reality zone okay
so once it's done playing just go back
to main full screen which is on the top
okay
okay go ahead you can do it you can do
it i'm going to do it right now okay
in 2019 the first strange realities
conference took place in nashville
tennessee
the pandemic in turmoil the following
year could not stop
2020's conference from thriving in
cyberspace as a live streaming event
now for 2021 the third annual strange
realities conference will combine these
worlds
into a paranormal hybrid event live in
person in nashville
and streaming online join us in
exploring just how truly strange our
reality can be
with an interdimensional lineup of
speakers presenting unique and
intellectual perspectives on magic
mysteries and the paranormal featuring
ellen greenfield dr j michael bennett
aka
dr future tim benall soraya
dr steven finley aaron gulias amy
pachula
brent raines chris ernst heather mosher
michael hughes jose herrera joshua
cutchen kiki dombrowski
nathan isaac pd newman stephen snyder
aka recluse david metcalf timothy renner
steve stockton and fred
[Music]
it's gonna be amazing
[Music]
see that [ __ ] i'm like at the [ __ ]
i'm at i'm at the damn
calm like i think some [ __ ] had a star
trek oh you see
see that [ __ ] now she's that she's ready
to come back okay well what'd you think
i'm not gonna
i didn't fall in i just i just had to
pee
how long do you think i was gonna hang
out in there
okay so we're back now yeah we're back
do you play the whole ad
yeah yeah really okay yeah that's maybe
that was shorter than i thought
because i felt like it felt like i
wasn't like uh
in there that long but uh yeah so i
forgot to mention
too that i mean during the investigation
when they were still like throwing
around different theories
uh because like i said they knew pretty
much from the start that this had to be
deliberate
so the first thing they were thinking
was like terrorism and
they did background checks on every
single person
that was on that plane including all the
crew including all the passengers
everything
now for a while we were going to that
conference
what oh probably not i mean i don't you
know
i don't have wow 13 o'clock as an ad
yeah we don't normally but
um adam sane like i said he's a friend
of ours from conspira normal
sandra's saying she forgot to look for
my butt when i got up
[Laughter]
all this sexism all this female gays
hey we're just getting ours back after
years and years and actually thousands
and thousands of years thousands of
years being the obvious
females getting the [ __ ] gays back
huh yeah okay
we're just gonna do although i don't
know dudes would probably just like it
so of course i think ignoring that is
probably like a better thing to do
so women always want vengeance they only
just care about vengeance that's it they
pretty much
they're not we're a vengeance based in
this country
yeah yeah in this case no everywhere i
don't think so well you know
i don't think so we're just some some
people are just quieter about it i don't
think so
[Laughter]
david jesus take your shirt off tom yeah
no if i'm taking my shirt off y'all
[ __ ] gotta pay me come on to be
a piece of meat you can do it you just
gotta pay me i don't think
yeah you haven't even put a wig on yet i
didn't even put a wig on we're like two
hours in and you have anything like [ __ ]
man i'm more
well don't we're more than like halfway
through this [ __ ] case and you
haven't even like put a wig on
we're gonna see which one which wig it's
gonna be which wig is it gonna be
okay yeah all right
yep considerably less sexy though okay
this week is not flattering at all man
it's not flattering at all
i don't know it does kind of give you a
certain this is [ __ ] yeah man it's
like i'm getting ready to listen to
[ __ ] journey
yeah molly hatchet you need to like but
you need to buy a trailer
yeah like live out and [ __ ] eustis
listen that new litter skinnered out
sit in a plastic chair in the front and
like drink some bud
listen to the hog yes
paying me to keep my shirt back on see
that's how it goes that's how it is
for two dollars that's just staying back
on
oh my god david june says lol i already
paid to see his pecs it's up to you all
this time
yeah xanada said that [ __ ] was a long
time ago dirt that's what it
that's what i called him when he first
put that put that wig on i called him
joe dirt
i don't think you've ever seen that
movie have you it's vince neil ross says
mega
tila says uh looking like dirk diggler
with that wig on yeah a little bit
uh yes thank you zach for time to be a
piece of meat now dance monkey dance
it's not enough money man
well how much would it take how much
would it take for you to just be a total
[ __ ]
[ __ ] man they're trying to [ __ ] [ __ ]
me out well i'm just well i'm curious
it's it's it's a rhetorical question
victor
look at victor thank you jenny show us
your ankles
you want to see an ankle there's an
ankle right there
kinda oh no i have bare feet i never
wear shoes
oh my god i'm trying to be serious about
this [ __ ] look
trying to be serious about this [ __ ]
all these like people are dead and
you're like just being
you and your [ __ ] is [ __ ] perfect
like [ __ ] yeah man
[ __ ] right man [ __ ] a [ __ ] ape
man
where's my eye rock yeah
yeah that's it thank you dude all the
money's [ __ ] coming in now we're
going to go for yourself for zach
myself this is where all these games is
where the money is
well okay okay i'm gonna put the other
[ __ ] i'm gonna put the other [ __ ] on
see you're trying you trying to like get
me to like show my boobs and stuff like
that like watch you do some [ __ ]
yeah why don't you do some [ __ ] gramster
says whoa move time
time zach says what is happening tonight
yeah well you know i wish i knew i never
know i never know what's going on
you're all right following falling down
okay there you go are you really that
much stronger than me yeah
i got my glasses on this is my professor
glasses i'm professor conan
oh that's making you professor clay
makes you smarter professor conan
i don't believe it yeah i'm gone
brad says uh tom has gone def con six
yeah pretty much
uh 13 o'clock after dark
oh my god hi everybody thank you
look at those jenny toes look at those
top nipples
yeah ew oh my god
this just went from like zero to a
hundred in like a second i just went to
the bathroom and look what happened
all that goddammit what happened like i
said i'm trying to talk about a serious
topic and you're like [ __ ] it up
norwegian death metal tom nice feet
they're not they're tiny i have tiny
tiny flat feet
i have tiny flat wide feet flat little
feet yeah
my feet are so ugly everybody's got ugly
feet
very rare to get that's true yeah i mean
you know
it's like i don't know it's like it's
too much to trouble like get this up
into the camera range
i'm not that i'm not that limber
anymore but yeah so are
are you done are you going to put a
shirt back back on right now what are
you doing
[Laughter]
you're just like you're very distracting
so go ahead go ahead do the show yeah
tom totally has a dancing thing going on
tom is the lost member of morbid angel
sure
uh yeah so what was where was i
zack says no for real tom you look great
may you continue on your tea journey
oh yeah man [ __ ] six months i'm gonna
look even better
[Laughter]
david thank you david june give us a
couple death metal verses
you know what he said yeah you know any
slayer of course
you know some slayer yeah
they want me to do some slayer right now
yeah well death metal
doesn't have to be played no [ __ ]
death metal right now man
come on do a cookie monster voice you
know you want to
aggressive discipline and barbaric
control thousands of people cannot be
wrong
okay yeah oscar says yeah
you cannot hide the face of death
aggression ruled by blood shed
[Laughter]
yep all right
so all right so i kind of lost my place
where was i
yeah so i was talking about
before you know he started doing that
[ __ ] i was talking about
a dude flying around at 35 000 feet with
230 something dead people in the back of
the plane because that really seems like
what happened
he intentionally allegedly depressurized
the cabin
and then maybe allegedly uh flew up
really fast
so it would depressurize the cabin even
faster so that the oxygen masks wouldn't
last as long
and everybody in the plane was just
sitting there with their oxygen masks on
presumably
and they would have just gone asleep and
died so you know he's flying around with
a
plateful of dead people for several
hours which like i said i don't know
that creeps me out for some reason
now um as sandra mentioned earlier
only good thing about this is that if
this is indeed what happened
which seems to be where the evidence is
pointing
that at least the passengers didn't
really know what was happening
probably the most alarming thing that
happened was that the
oxygen masks dropped down and they were
like oh better put some oxygen masks on
and they put them on and then
a few minutes later they would have just
fallen asleep and died um
you know from hypoxia which is what they
call it and they actually
they do that with um you know pilots
in the military and in the you know if
you're flying an airplane or whatever
they do like hypoxia tests on you so
they make you
they give you like that lack of oxygen
thing and it's almost kind of like a
euphoric
you feel like euphoric and then you just
kind of like drift off into sleep and
you go unconscious
and if it continues then you'll die
because like i said you don't have
oxygen
but you're not really like aware of it
so i'm kind of hoping
if this had to happen i'm kind of hoping
that's what happened because those
people probably just like fell asleep
and didn't
know what was going on so yeah
now at this point the okay so the crazy
[ __ ]
nobody's entirely sure the thing about
it is that no one's entirely sure
if because the cockpit had oxygen masks
too but they had a lot more oxygen
than anybody in the cabin did like i
said in the cabin it was like 12
15 minutes um in the cockpit
it's more like a couple hours worth of
oxygen right because like i said they
have to fly the [ __ ] so it's uh you know
it's
lasts a lot longer in there no one's
really sure
if he did the same thing to himself at
some point
or i kind of feel like more evidence is
pointing to him just like
flying the plane for several hours
and then deliberately diving into the
ocean
no one's really sure if he just
decided hey i'm out and like he did
hypoxia himself
at some point um and then just let the
plane run out of fuel
and then to crash into the ocean or if
he
was with it if he was awake all the way
to the end and then said i'm going to
crash this [ __ ] into the ocean
what are you doing well damn pokey what
are you asking for
what are you doing hey what's up
you wanna go outside you wanna it's hot
out there though
what's that she's looking at him she's
looking at the wig like what the [ __ ] is
that where were you
come here let's go what is with your
hair daddy
oh she doesn't like that oh i put a
collar on it
she has to have you have to have your
clothes on yeah but um
okay yeah so the thing about it it's
like it's crazy because
at some point and they didn't really
find this out until later on
because like i said the malaysian
government was a little
they kept everything a little secretive
because i think they didn't want to look
like incompetent or like they didn't
know what they were doing
so at some point they had the plane had
like pinged on the military radar
and actually the people that were
monitoring the radar at the time did
actually see the plane
but and they knew that it wasn't really
supposed to be there
but they didn't really do anything about
it because they said oh it's just it's
friendly it's just a passenger plane
and they didn't really think anything
else about it so
they didn't you know that i'm not
necessarily saying that
because i was watching a documentary and
the guy was like yeah but
even if like yeah we saw it and stuff
what were you supposed to do just like
send jets up there to like shoot it down
or whatever
and i don't know they said well you
could have at least like gone up there
and like seen what the [ __ ] was going on
like you could have looked in the car
like looked in the cockpit and see who
was
flying it or you could have like you
know there's things you could have done
and they didn't do it
because they were just kind of like oh
it's just one of it's fine it's probably
all fine
and they didn't do anything about it so
you know um
that's it's kind of shitty but so
basically
so basically the this pilot if the pilot
zahari was the one that did it uh
he basically kills everyone in the plane
by depressurizing the cabin so he's
flying around
for several hours um
with a bunch of dead people in his plane
and then he arrives at some spot in the
indian ocean
and either deliberately crashes the
plane into the ocean or
he just lets it run out until it runs
out of fuel which it would have
around that time because like i said
there's only about seven hours and 45
minutes worth of fuel in the plane
which was pretty standard now
it's interesting because i just
uh man i i just kind of feel like
this is just so [ __ ] weird this dude
um where did oh he's coming back
here i kind of like
lost my place i was gonna say something
and then i forgot but
another thing that's kind of pointing to
this being a suicide mission
that i think i forgot to bring up
earlier was that after the plane
uh you know did its hairpin turn like
off its route and then kind of went
back down across malaysia and then
banked the place where it banked
was over an island called penang and
penang happened to be where captain
zahari
that was his hometown so it's almost
kind of like
he turned around flew back over and then
he was like tipping his wing
to like hey that's my hometown never
going to see that again
or like you almost like he was saying
goodbye to it
and then he went out in the middle of
the indian ocean now they think that the
reason that he went out there and i was
watching
um if you guys on youtube there's a dude
named dr grande
and he's like a psychiatrist and he puts
up like a [ __ ] ton of videos and he's
always like analyzing
like different like mental health issues
and stuff and he's really
he's funny because he's really really
knowledgeable and he has like a sense of
humor but it is like
the driest sense of humor ever so it's
like he never he hardly ever like cracks
a smile
but then like sometimes he'll say
something that's just like super super
funny and it will just like crack me up
but he never like laughs you know what i
mean because he's like super
like deadpan and it just [ __ ] cracks
me up
so he did a he did a video about this
case um kind of predicated on
the theory that the captain was trying
to
kill himself and had decided that he was
going to take this whole plane load of
people with him for whatever reason
now his analysis was one
that this is a guy that was probably
like suffering from depression for
whatever reason
and was trying to get revenge
against society at large or at least
felt like society at large was like
against him or was like
[ __ ] on him or whatever and so this
plain load of people
was representative of that uh so he's
like well i'm just gonna take them out
with me
and it'll be a big thing and um the
reason
and i i saw a lot of other people uh say
this too
the reason that he deliberately seemed
to uh fly it in the middle of the
indian ocean in this kind of like remote
place where
you know the weather was shitty and like
not a lot of you know
there wasn't a lot of like activity
going on was because he wanted
to disappear like he wanted to
not he didn't want to be one of those
guys that was kind of like oh i'm going
to like take everybody out with mood
they want to be like famous
it's almost kind of like he just wanted
to take revenge against people like
society in general but also he wanted to
kind of [ __ ] with everybody by saying
i'm going to go to like the most remote
place i can think
of and put this plane in there and like
no one will ever find it
so you're saying it's kind of like the
uh kind of like a bigger version
of that kid who got into a i'll call him
a kid he's about 30 something
had a promising future gets up in his
little single engine [ __ ] cessna
radios in a ufo report saying that the
ufo was right on his tail
and then you never hear from him again
yeah do you hear about that one yeah
yeah yeah but he
but pretty much but because of the radar
and everything they know that he [ __ ]
crashed the airplane into the [ __ ]
into the water yeah it's happened like
more than once and zach actually just
brought up wasn't there a case in
germany a few years back where something
real similar to that happened
yeah and actually that happened i think
a year maybe a year or two after this
case and it was a german dude he was
actually the co-pilot he wasn't the
actual pilot
and he did what they think happened in
this where he told
the pilot well like he waited for the
pilot to go to the bathroom
and then he locked the pilot out of the
cockpit and then
crashed the plane into the alps
uh and killed everybody on board 200
something people um
so that was and they think that it was
because of depression it was suicide
it's murder suicide which it doesn't
happen that often but it has happened
before
so as weird as that is like i can't
imagine
i can't imagine what your mindset would
have to be like
to not only want to like kill yourself
which like i said isn't that
weird but to want to take a whole
plane load of innocent people that don't
have anything to do with you
with you and also to fly the plane
very deliberately to a place where he
was sure that probably
it wouldn't be found because it seemed
like
everything that he did if he if this was
indeed what happened like they're not
entirely certain but this is what all
the evidence points to
if this was indeed what happened he
very deliberately planned this
the fact that he turned the plane
seconds after he was being handed off to
another country's airspace
um knowing probably and he had flown
this route many times
knowing that probably there would be
some confusion and it would be a while
before they would realize what had
happened
so it seemed almost kind of like he knew
he knew that he was um you know going
toward an area that was going to be
like that it was going to be really
difficult to find it it'd be really
difficult
um before they even started looking for
them
you know i don't he didn't know about
the pinging of the of the radar from
like the
satellite he didn't know about that but
he did very deliberately it seems like
turned the transponder off so they
couldn't track him he didn't know that
there was still a satellite tracking him
because
most pilots didn't know that at the time
it just wasn't it happened automatically
um and like i said i saw a couple
documentaries and they talked to other
pilots that had flown
boeing 777s and they said yeah in 2014
we didn't know that show was going on
either we didn't know it was ping in the
satellite every half an hour because
that was just like an automatic thing
and it wasn't anything to do with us so
they're like if i
if we didn't know it he probably didn't
know that either um but he was
definitely trying to maintain radio
silence and trying to stay
he was trying to go to a specific place
he was trying to go to a place that he
knew that it was very unlikely that the
plane would be found or that it would be
intercepted or anything like that it
just seems to me that that's kind of
like what he was doing
so what i forgot to mention earlier was
when they were doing the background
checks on all the people in the plane
because like i said
at the time they were kind of like maybe
one of the passengers was a terrorist
and maybe he took over or whatever
and for a time there was kind of a thing
where
um they made a big deal about two guys
that were on the plane that were
iranian and they were like and they had
stolen passports so they're like maybe
these two guys were terrorists but they
like looked more into them
and then they figured out that those two
dudes they only had stolen passports
because they were trying to get the [ __ ]
out of iran they were trying to get to
europe um and they said they were asylum
seekers
and uh so and they none and neither one
of them had enough uh flying experience
to have pulled off a stunt like this
so the more that they kind of like look
into the evidence the more
it seems like it was probably the
captain that did that kind of [ __ ] and
he did it very very deliberately
and i'll get into um
one thing that they found which to me
seems like a smoking gun
i'm not really sure uh because what they
did
when they were you know in the aftermath
of the incident which like i said they
really did
investigate it wasn't just the malaysian
government because like i said nobody
would trust anything
like coming out of there necessarily but
it was a chinese government it was the
australian government it was the fbi it
was all kind of different like
you know uh agencies like working in
tandem like to try to figure out what
happened
so they did like background checks on
every single person in the plane that
was a passenger they did all the
crew members everything and they felt
like nothing there was nothing
weird about anybody that was in there
however when they looked into
captain zahari's back like they searched
his house and his computers and all this
other kind of stuff
because they wanted to see you know was
he a terrorist so you know who knows
so they looked into his stuff and
remember how early on in the show
i said that he was real into like
aviation in general
and he had all these he had a flight
simulator program that he
and they said he played with it all the
time um
one of the flight simulations that he
had done was pretty much
the exact route that this plane took
who did this the captain the captain
yeah and it was on his computer and
he had done it like a month or two
before and they said interestingly yeah
they said interestingly he done like a
bunch of different simulations on there
but the simulations that he had done
usually you put in all the coordinates
and then you let the simulation
run they said this particular one he had
put in the coordinates but then he
manually went through
the thing like he was practicing yeah
kind of
like allegedly um so they thought that
was a they said that's
unlikely to be a coincidence and that's
why i say
that this flight trajectory that he took
pretty much ended and he even like
adjusted like the fuel
and everything like he so he knew where
the plane would run out of fuel
he so he knew where he was going he
wanted to go
into the middle of the indian ocean
where it would be unlikely that the
plane would be found
and it just really seems to me like his
mental state was of a kind
that i'm gonna fly to this place and
that'll be i don't know if
i don't know if it was like a [ __ ] you
like you'll never find the plane and
you'll never find all these people which
would be shitty
or if he was just so [ __ ] up that he's
just like i just want to disappear off
the face of the earth and i don't want
anybody to ever find me
you know what i mean so i it could go
either way
because everybody like they did
background checks on him because he had
worked for malaysia airlines for like
decades right it's like and he was a
very senior pilot he was very respected
nothing weird in his record they said he
hadn't been acting weird lately
they even have there's footage of him
and like the passengers and stuff like
before the
flight you know where he killed
everybody um allegedly
and uh he was just acting totally normal
nobody act
said that he was acting weird or
anything so
there was nothing in his past to suggest
that
but the weird thing was that there was
an official report done they did a
background report on him and like i said
you know he had a wife he had three
grown kids he had like money he had like
a couple houses
he was doing okay he seemed all right
but then
it seemed like the malaysian government
put that out like oh he had a spotless
record there was nothing to suggest blah
blah blah
but allegedly um other reporters that
went to the country and talked to people
that knew him and like family members
and stuff they said yeah um
you know he was a he was a good guy like
he seemed like a cool guy and everything
he was a little laid back and whatnot
but it's like lately his wife had left
him
uh had moved into the other house um he
seemed kind of
sad he seemed kind of lonely there was a
thing where
like i said he was real active on social
media and they said that
he had apparently become obsessed
with these two real young uh facebook or
instagram models
and he would like leave kind of not
nothing horrible but like a couple of
like you know vaguely sexual
comments on their pictures like
several times which were never answered
um so
and and one other person that like
worked with him a lot said
you know everybody like yeah he was
banging some of the um
uh flight crew like you know the
stewardesses or whatever
um but everybody did that but his wife
knew about it well that's what this guy
said it's like oh there's all these
beautiful young women and you're
flying to other cities and you just kind
of have to do it
but how old was this dude 53
53. so it's possible
and like they've kind of speculated that
maybe hormonal maybe his wife had left
him
and maybe he was like obsessed with
these much much younger women
um because i've seen pictures of the
models that he was obsessed when they
were like his daughter's age
yeah and he had like he had kids like
that age
yeah but you know scientifically it's
been proven though
guys are attracted to a certain age set
it doesn't change how old they are
about the same and they guys don't
really
kind of in terms of because
once a woman goes outside a certain age
bracket
she's not in the market basically she's
not interested doesn't matter who you
are
tila said his wife didn't care i think
she did i think she left actually yeah
so
apparently she right or she didn't i
think she knew about it and she took off
a lot of times a woman hits menopause
she doesn't give a [ __ ] this is just
like i was telling
jenny in brazil in the culture there
the wives brazil does brazil when i was
living there
and growing up there they didn't approve
of divorce you could have divorced but
that was like bad
okay guys tended to keep their wives and
their families
they would kind of unofficially break up
with the
with the wife but you didn't divorce her
you know what i mean
you kept it as part of your family you
kept supporting her
and then they picked up younger
girlfriends the wives knew
but they didn't care they were sick of
[ __ ] that dude
that's just you know i mean it was the
the um
divorce was a bigger in that culture
like a bigger [ __ ] i guess you could
say
stigma than it was the whole [ __ ]
lover situation
and the woman was kind of free to do
whatever she wanted you know she was
free you know so it wasn't a
it wasn't a problem but it sounds like
this situation might have been something
like that
maybe he was in a loveless situation his
wife left him
he might have been going through 53 well
his wife might have left him because of
that though because
apparently he'd been like stalking these
two girls online well allegedly like
about that dude well you foreign know
her it's just
it's just you know you're gonna have
guys in the comment section that'll
[ __ ] probably chime in
once it gets to that point the wife
usually doesn't care
um but the thing is is that he's
interested in these younger women but
there's no way he's going to get that
okay which adds to depression and then
he's going through andrenopause
life isn't what he thought it was
depression kicks in [ __ ] ends up
getting suicidal
that sounds like it sounds like
adrenopause which is like menopause
or postpartum depression that women go
through it's what it sounds like
grandpa's hammer says my wife [ __ ]
rocks by the way yeah
that's nice that's nice of you to say
actually
that's i'm not being sarcastic that's
totally totally legit
some women as they get older they
[ __ ] you know
stay fun some of them don't it just
depends on what the situation is
um but a lot of times if you look at
what the hell's going on it's
kind of a [ __ ] you know
i guess you could say it's not a real
strict situation there isn't a lot of
jealousy involved and it's just
it's just business at that point
because it you know people in their 50s
are not the same as people in their
teenage years
i mean when we hang out with the kids
you look they get jealous over [ __ ]
anything
you see that it's kind of [ __ ] funny
yes you saw that [ __ ]
she's getting [ __ ] jealous over
nothing over women that have blonde hair
and who's an old lady now yeah who's
like an old lady now and
like that girl's [ __ ] 60 now what do
you mean you know
he likes her she's 60 now she's gone
you know [ __ ] she you know he yeah we
were talking about something like a rock
star yeah we're talking about a rock
star got him is jittan timon
he liked jatan damone and she was
jealous of chitanda bone
like that woman's [ __ ] 60s yeah she's
got it she's an old lady now i think
okay and she and the jealousy was is
that she was blonde
what are you talking about [ __ ]
aaliyah is
physically actually cuter than jaton de
monde not a moment was a [ __ ] singer
but you know
there was it's a different dynamic but
she did anything to be jealous about
that girl's gone
yeah but it's like well i will kind of
chime in that says it's kind of like
it's depressing that like whatever
because i feel like women are kind of in
a situation where
even if you're young and cute like
whatever you do
it's like the dude's always kind of like
oh look at that blonde chick and you
always kind of feel like there's
something wrong with you because it's
like
oh well he likes that well he doesn't
like this now like he's bored of it so
it's kind of like you know
there's always he just that's how it
comes across though
it's how it comes across to women that's
not how it comes across to other men
because we don't have the emotions
involved we know what it is we don't
have emotions
it says tom i'm gonna put that on a
shirt too i didn't say that
yeah yeah we don't know i said i'm gonna
put that on a shirt but we don't have
the same emotions
we're not experiencing the same emotions
women are experiencing
we see a guy doing that we know what it
is we're not we don't really think it's
a big deal
you know what are you doing pope
oh is she back there yes i heard a weird
noise okay
yeah i was going to say it was still
kind of daylight in this pot house yeah
yeah it's [ __ ] hot yeah she's not
going to go out when it's hot she
doesn't like it
does she ever call her all those no
because she didn't go out because she
was like [ __ ]
well yeah so i so i don't know how
treating this is but um
that was like something that was
speculated because that was brought up
because the official story was um
you know this dude was like an
unimpeachable like family man like he
had a wife he had three grown kids which
he did and he was still in contact with
them it wasn't like
it wasn't like they were estranged or
anything like that but
um when they started looking deeper into
it when other
uh you know journalists and stuff
started looking deeper into it
they said maybe it wasn't as cut and
dried as that
like oh this dude is just this normal
family man and suddenly he just like
flipped out and decided he was gonna
kill himself and everybody on this plane
uh he might have had some other uh
issues
and so that's when they started
uncovering like the weird social media
stuff like with the
with the models and uh you know the fact
that maybe his wife had left him and
like moved out of the house
and so maybe like it wasn't as
you know maybe his life wasn't as
awesome as they were trying to make it
appear
um you know so maybe he did have like
some reason for doing what he did
although like i said what he did was uh
pretty extreme
gotta say that well you might have been
crazy too yeah
although like i said uh you know nobody
he had worked for this company for like
a million years and like
you know not a million years but a
couple decades and you know
nobody really said anything about they
said he was just like a normal nice dude
it's like nobody
got in a rut yeah i i kind of feel like
maybe it just did and there was a lot of
[ __ ] going on maybe in his
mind that people didn't know about maybe
he didn't like share a lot of stuff with
people
so it's kind of that thing so uh zach
brought some stuff up earlier about how
this
poo stop tearing up the blood
look at that she's like but you're not
paying attention
yeah he brought up a case earlier um
you know because as weird as this sounds
like i'm gonna kill myself
and i'm a pilot and i'm gonna take a
whole plane load of people with me as
[ __ ] up as that sounds
uh this has happened before like i said
it's rare
but it does happen uh so there were a
couple other cases there was one in 1997
uh and there was a guy he was uh the
captain of the airline
he worked it was a singaporean airline
silk air
and they think that this dude
disabled the black boxes on the boeing
737 he was flying
and basically dove the plane into a
river
uh killing everyone on board so there
was that
1999 uh there was a
guy who was the co-pilot on egypt air
flight 990 and he also crashed into the
sea
uh off the coast of long island that was
uh 2000
that was 1999 rather and also killed
everyone on board
and uh there was another one too this
was 2013. this wasn't too long before
uh the malaysia airlines thing happened
there was a dude he was a captain of the
um mozambique airlines
flight 470 and he actually flew his uh
plane from cruising altitude into the
ground
uh there were 27 passengers and six crew
members aboard
all of whom were killed and the one that
zach was talking about was
um and this happened in 2014 actually
after
the uh the malaysian airlines and they
think that maybe this co-pilot got the
idea
from that uh so because this guy was a
co-pilot his name was
uh andreas lubitz and he waited for the
pilot to go to the bathroom as i
mentioned earlier locked him out of the
cockpit
and then crashed the plane into
the alps so you know that was march of
2015.
so like i said this is not unprecedented
it's a really really
[ __ ] up way to kill yourself uh
seems convoluted but
i don't know i can't say that i
understand the psychology necessarily
because i would never
in a million years take other people
with me because why the [ __ ] would you
do that
i mean those people didn't choose to
give i mean
you know he probably wasn't looking at
that if you can like choose to kill
yourself fine but it's just like i'm
dude i'm even
a kind of person where if you're gonna
choose to kill yourself
at least do it in a like a not messy way
so other people don't have to clean up
your [ __ ] carcass
and i think we like brought that up
before because we were talking about how
well in the in the late victorian era
there was a thing where like some people
and i even wrote about a couple cases
like this where a couple dudes it was
always dudes
would kill themselves by jumping in
front of a train
and i was just like dude the the person
driving the train and all the people on
the train are traumatized now
now all the people that had to like
clean up your [ __ ]
splattered carcass or traumatize now so
good job
like just don't [ __ ] do that holy
crap i had a friend when i was up in
boston she was in mental health and she
took care of a whole bunch of mental
mental outpatients
and some of them would commit suicide
she knew all about that she told me
about it one time she said that
guys have a tendency to commit suicide
in real violent
ways yeah i know they do punish people
who see it
i know you want to make a big show about
it women tend to do it kind of in
non-violent private ways like pills
and they want to make it setting
warnings for people and [ __ ]
what are you surprised when you open the
door because i just killed myself that
type of
well yeah because you don't want to like
you don't want to put other people out
you don't want to like traumatize other
people why would you want to do that
[ __ ] up just the mental makeup of some
man is some
certain dudes they're trying to punish
everybody else all right which is dumb
because no one feels punished they're
just kind of like what the [ __ ]
[ __ ]
you're not seeing it through the eyes of
a dude who's mentally ill
he's trying to lash back [ __ ] you
[ __ ] you [ __ ] destroyed me
i'm gonna destroy all of you
it's it's kind of a vengeance i get that
i just don't feel that this whole system
is [ __ ] up and it was
you guys came at me with this [ __ ] and
you all need to [ __ ] punish for this
[ __ ] it's not right
i'm right you're wrong boom you know but
uh
guys would do all kinds of weird [ __ ]
according to her [ __ ] one of the
things that they do is they also like to
make themselves
[ __ ] suffer you know what i mean like
like a non-violent way of a guy killing
himself is to [ __ ] blow his head off
with a [ __ ] pistol
if he wanted to do it violently then
he'd pour gasoline on himself and set
himself on fire
in front of other people that was and
that was
not only making themselves suffer but
that was the idea to make other people
suffer to see it
it's show business you know what i mean
show business
it's uh socio sociopathy yeah
well it's because who wrote all that
[ __ ] well i'm gonna pissed off
[ __ ] and he's trying to lash out
he does well the thing about it
is that what's funny is that they set
themselves on fire a lot of times they'd
survive it
and then they'd be sitting there with
their skin burned off going on
well the thing about it and i was i was
thinking about this earlier in the
context of
something else it might have been in the
context of this but i was reading about
something else earlier and it kind of
like reminded me of this
i kind of feel like dudes in general
not everybody dudes in general have a
thing where they actually
think that the world at large or like
other people
care about what they do or what their
opinions are
um so and that kind of feeds into
because like you said
if they're going to kill themselves they
just kind of like
hey [ __ ] i'm punishing you and
it's just kind of like no one
feels punished because no one gives that
much of a [ __ ] about you but it's just
kind of like i don't
i don't know why dudes have that mindset
that they think other people
care what they do or care about what
their motivation oh it depends on the
situation
it depends on the situation because guys
sometimes understand it it all depends
on how clear-cut it is
like the dude that got in the winnebago
and he rigged that thing up with a bomb
and went and [ __ ] blew himself up
over in nashville the other day
outside that t outside that a t and t
building
and he's even [ __ ] broadcasting get
away from the vehicle it's going to blow
up he's even doing accounting
for some reason he thought that was a
good idea it had something to do with
that building when that building blew up
all the built all the windows blew out
and behind those windows were just more
bricks
so it was a hardened building an att
building
so he must he believed a t with 18 t was
up to some
it it must be that a a t and t is a c i
a front
as i was thinking about some do some
communications he was trying to [ __ ]
destroy
now they came out with a cover story the
media did well he
was he was against 5g but they never
really showed
that as evidence i think for some reason
he thought he was going to war with the
c.i.a
and when's those [ __ ] yeah how'd that
go now he was willing to die for it
though he didn't care
well now he's dead and it didn't really
do any good did it
him living didn't do any good either
well yeah but i'm saying
i kind of look at it from your point of
view well no i'm kind of feeling like
the point i'm trying to make is that a
lot of these kind of dudes have a way
inflated sense of their own importance a
way inflated since then well that's why
guys [ __ ] go to war with each other
and [ __ ] throw themselves up on a
battle because they really think they're
something it's like no one cares about
you dude they get [ __ ] done though they
got [ __ ] down do they
they get [ __ ] done i was like yeah i
blew myself up in a winnebago and i was
like yeah good job now everybody just
thinks you're a lunatic
so i don't really know what that
accomplished it was the same thing as
dudes [ __ ]
going through the [ __ ] atlantic wall
and fighting the nazis it's that same
[ __ ] mentality
it's just for some reason he thought
there was something in that building
that needed to be exposed i guess
you know you don't know what it is i
don't know what it is but he thought he
knew what it was
well i'm sure it's probably nothing i'm
sure that dude was probably like
maybe he was probably a loon maybe it's
hard to say
maybe he was a [ __ ] secret agent you
don't know
it's a lot of [ __ ] i doubt it i doubt it
oh no there was a lot of secret agent
[ __ ] that went down and then they said
oh that didn't happen
that didn't happen but it was secret
agent [ __ ] but i mean
many times the thing about it like i
said it's just kind of like
this case was really making me think
about
because this dude and you know if he was
having
uh problems with depression and stuff
which allegedly
he probably was and he wanted to kill
himself
i don't understand why you wouldn't just
kill yourself and not involve other
people that had nothing to do with you
we don't know that that's what happened
though well i'm just saying most of the
evidence points to that
and that's kind of right you know i
don't buy it's impossible
yeah i don't buy it i mean honestly at
pretty much everything
every piece of evidence that they have
like points to
it being deliberate now the only other
maybe plausible theory that i've seen
was that
um at some point in the few seconds
after his normal uh radio call-in before
he was handed off to vietnamese airspace
was that maybe possibly uh something
catastrophic happened in the cabin like
a fire or something like that
and he decided he was gonna like turn
around real quick and try to land again
but then when he knew that it wasn't uh
you know gonna be sorted out he said
well i'm gonna crash the plane out of
the ocean
so i don't crash on land and like you
know hurt people on land or whatever
but the fact that he flew for such
a long time after that he might have
been dead
so that's a possibility also so maybe
he's a hero
i don't know maybe he just said i don't
want to crash the plane on land and i'm
going to do this and maybe he died at
some point and the plane just
kept going on autopilot and then it ran
out of fuel and then it crashed into the
ocean
because like i said they're not entirely
sure
i mean from at least the satellite data
they're pretty sure
that the plane hit the ocean
really really quickly as if allegedly
somebody deliberately dove it
into the ocean um there is some
debate about this though because i've
seen like i saw this uh
australian documentary i think it was
like a 60 minutes and they had two guys
on there one guy thinking
i think the the dude uh you know
deliberately
dove it into the ocean the other one
saying i think the dude was already
dead from hypoxia and he just and the
plane just ran out of fuel and just like
[ __ ]
went into a death spiral and went to the
ocean because like i said those are
going to be two different
things because if you're diving into the
ocean it's going to be like way faster
so there's still a debate about that but
no one's debating whether it was uh
deliberate or not the only thing they're
they're debating is maybe there was
another because they haven't found the
plane
they haven't found the bodies um you
know
it's just marginally possible that it
could have been
like a third party uh as in somebody
else that was on the plane that it
stowed away or a terrorist or whatever
but that possibility seems
unlikely um so they think like the most
likely
scenario is that the pilot or maybe the
co-pilot although he didn't really have
a motive
um probably deliberately
did this as a murder suicide and as i
said it's happened before
now what the psychology was like i said
i get it intellectually but i don't feel
that way so it's like really
hard for me to i would never in a
million years if i was gonna take
myself out i would never ever
[ __ ] take anyone else with me ever
and not only
would i not do that like i said if i was
gonna take myself out i would take
myself out in the most like
low-key way possible i don't want
somebody having to clean up my
splattered remains off a [ __ ] train
track or something [ __ ] like that holy
crap
why would you do that to somebody well
you're a nice person
yeah okay sorry yeah
i know i know that's like a joke don't
project your good nature onto others
[ __ ] might have been just bad
you know and he kind of bad and he was
mad
so that's what he did yeah
i'm not justifying it but that's what it
was i'm just saying i don't even know
it's weird i didn't know the dude and
it's just kind of like but
if that's what happened from everything
that i've heard
and seen of like him prior to that
i don't even know if it was so much
anger i think it was just
i think that he thought that
he was just like not i don't i don't
know
it more seems to me like he thought he
wasn't worth anything
and so he just i wouldn't read into it
i mean no i'm just saying there are two
possibilities either he could have been
and
like i said dr grande who's his
psychiatrist and he kind of looked into
this case
and he thought well probably this is the
type of dude and you see this a lot in
like mass shooters and that
kind of [ __ ] where it's just kind of
like i'm gonna punish
all these innocent people that have
nothing to do with you um
you know because you know society [ __ ]
me or whatever it's like a religion
um no one ever really uh brought that up
though because that doesn't really seem
like anything that was that important to
that dude
that you know it's difficult to say some
dudes [ __ ] they can lose their job
and all of a sudden they're saying the
world is wrong this isn't what i was
told and
uh you know i mean [ __ ] none of this
shit's fair
and [ __ ] you know they could be
anywhere america's gone germany's gone
australia's gone whatever it is you know
you [ __ ] are all
failing and i'm failing and [ __ ] it
let's end the world you know it's just
it's just you're reading too much into
it it's kind of like mental illness it's
just
you know well it is i'm not reading into
it i'm just trying to like figure trying
to make too much sense out of it what
his motivation that [ __ ] didn't
and other people well honestly um he had
to put
a great deal of thought into it because
he planned it yeah for a long time
but it was gonna it's gonna be something
banal it's gonna be something very
benal if you heard it you're like that's
it it's good yeah well it was emotion
that's doing this
not which like i said if i was one of
the family members of the people that
disappeared i'd be really pissed
uh to hear that it was just some banal
reason oh yeah some random
dude decided they were bummed out about
life
because their wife left and it's like
i'm gonna kill 230 odd
there was no future random people that
didn't have anything to do
with your [ __ ] depression is [ __ ]
powerful he is i know
he's like [ __ ] man they lied to me
life didn't turn out the way i thought
it was i did everything right it still
didn't work
there's no future for me [ __ ] this [ __ ]
all these people are
bad but [ __ ] like i get that it's gonna
be like i get that mindset
what i don't know i'm gonna take them
all with me they all deserve it
it's it's gonna be something but that's
what i mean i get the whole thing it's
like yeah life's not fair
like everything sucks i get that i get
wanted to take yourself out i get that
um you know i do what i don't get is
that
next step i'm gonna take all these
people that don't have anything because
because when you're a dude like that
then you're saying like they're not
gonna be anything either
they don't matter either if they come
with me then i'm [ __ ] just saving
them
from all this [ __ ] [ __ ] it's it's
like that you know what i mean
so we'll just put an end to it they're
going to come with me and it won't
matter because none of this [ __ ] matters
and the fact that he's futures don't
matter it's going to be
like that and the fact that he seemed to
have allegedly flown this plane
yeah to a spot in the indian ocean which
he seemed very aware
was going to be like really difficult to
recover which indeed
has proved to be because they haven't
recovered it yet well could it could be
he didn't want anybody know that it
happened well he didn't seem to be
well maybe he thought that he would just
disappear off a radar and it would be a
mystery forever and no one would ever
know
well he did seem to think that initially
because like i said he really did seem
to deliberately
uh turn the [ __ ] around like right while
he was in between the two countries
airspace
and he as i said he had flown that route
several times before
so yeah so it's like they probably won't
find me for like several hours so i can
go off into the middle of the ocean and
like disappear
in this like random area and
that's like like i said i i understand
it i just don't
you know i i can't i don't know if
empathize is the right word but it's
just like i don't feel like that
yeah and i don't and i can't imagine
what it must be like
to you know like i said i can imagine
what it must be like to be like oh life
sucks and it's like you want to take
yourself out i get that but it's like i
don't
get wanting to like take people just
random ass people
why would you do that because xanada
says it right there suicidal isn't very
far from homicidal it's the same street
yeah exactly i don't agree though but
it's because maybe it manifests
differently
yeah it might manifest differently
because
i like you said before when women kill
themselves it usually tends to be like
in a kind of quiet
yeah way and they don't you don't see
women like taking out a bunch of like
innocent people no because why would you
do that women
they don't have anything to do with your
problems well i i already [ __ ] went
through this with that [ __ ] woman i
can't remember her name now
she was my she was my neighbor up in
boston
when women kill themselves they're just
leaving they're punishing themselves in
a way
when men kill themselves they're lashing
out at others they're going to [ __ ]
punish other people too
that's which is why they are very very
different which is why they're a menace
men are a menace yeah okay no i'm just
saying it's a
that's because that would never ever
occur to me to do that
well because why would that ever occur
man when a man goes suicidal there's a
lot of angered hatred in it
well i'm not like i feel anger i feel
hatred
but it's not directed necessarily i mean
some of it's
necessary i just wouldn't
do that you're talking and you're not
listening if you're going to kill
yourself
how can they punish you for killing
other people they can't so they do it
that's why it's free
that's a [ __ ] up way of thinking
though yeah yeah dudes are [ __ ] up
dude do you guys really like all think
like that holy crap no no no i need off
this planet
i need off this planet like right now no
they don't all think like that it's just
the [ __ ] you know that's what they're
thinking
honestly that would really never occur
to me yeah
[ __ ] hormones are a hell of a drug
that's what i mean y'all are a menace
well
that was just that's just something that
would just never occur to me
i would never i gotta go to the restroom
hold on you know like i said
i understand like people i don't wanna
be here anymore i understand
that that's not weird um you know
it's sad but it's not weird what i don't
understand
is i feel bad
and want to die and want to be out of
here
and then going forward from that too all
of these
people who have nothing to do with [ __ ]
that's wrong with me
also should die and you're ruining all
these other people's lives because i
just i do not understand that mindset at
all
so i don't know in a way it's
interesting because i was watching
uh as i said there were a couple of
australian documentaries about this case
one that was like a 60 minutes
you know the australian version of 60
minutes and one was i can't remember
what the other one was called
but um i watched it they're both on
youtube so i watched a couple of those
and they talked to a couple of these
survivors
of you know family members of people
that have been killed in the
uh in the crash um that were australian
new zealanders whatever
and interestingly both of the ones they
talked to
who one of them i think her husband of
14 years
had been killed he was going to china
for a job
and he had disappeared and
the other one i think it was her
[Music]
mother-in-law or was it her mother no
her sister and her
or her sister and her brother-in-law
that's what the other that's what the
other one was
and she both of them said interestingly
that they would not even though
like the host of the show was like look
all the evidence
points to the captain um
essentially committing suicide and
taking all of your family members
uh with him so like how do you feel
about that and
they were actually uh probably a lot
more charitable than i would have been
because they said look
um we have been raised it's like we will
not
lay blame until we know what the
complete truth is no one has found the
plane
no one has found the bodies um even
though all the evidence seems to point
in the direction
of the cat of the captain deliberately
crashing the plane in a suicide
in a murder-suicide um we're not going
to condemn him because
um we don't want to unless until we know
like what actually happened you know we
don't want to cast aspersions on the man
because he has a family they're still
alive
and so and i was like i was almost kind
of like taken aback by that because i'm
like that's
actually and these are people whose
family members were
killed were disappeared um and
the fact that they were still willing to
give the dude that much latitude
it's like yeah we're not going to blame
him until we know exactly what happened
because that's not cool because he has a
family too and
and he's also dead um you know so
and maybe it wasn't him maybe it was the
co-pilot maybe it was a
you know an unknown third party maybe as
a terrorist which it could have been
um it's unlikely but it could have been
um you know again the co-pilot unlikely
but it could have been
so she's like we're not gonna we're not
gonna like
you know [ __ ] on that dude because we
don't know
um so i was kind of like
but i don't know i i had a lot of like
uh admiration
for the survivors there in that
situation because
as i said i'm not sure
that i would be that charitable in that
situation and the fact that they could
be that charitable was like actually
kind of like trying to put a collar on
her but she got running from me
well she didn't go outside did she she
acted like she wanted to
yeah well she always acts like she wants
yeah i'm gonna get a collar and she
starts running
um get back what you're talking about i
think what makes a man kill himself and
what makes a woman kill himself the
emotions i think are very different
what's making a man kill himself is
[ __ ] anger i think mostly
well so he's already just going kamikaze
and what makes a woman kill herself is
very different more like
just you know mopey oh [ __ ] it i'm out
of here it's not mopey
we feel anger too you know that right
it's just that
i think it's the thing about it is that
dudes in general yeah tend to blame
others for their problems uh women tend
to blame
themselves yeah that might be true that
might be true
generally yeah so i think that might go
down right that's right describing what
i'm just good
why are you making this happen he
constantly constantly makes fun of me
i'm not making friends that might be
true though i don't know i don't know
i don't know it is true i think it is
true no i'm just saying it might be that
what makes a man
mad is things that other people do
and they might i mean i get mad at what
other people do too but
it's like i understand that i can't do
anything about other people's nothing
wrong with men
there's nothing wrong with women it's
just a different viewpoint and that
they're
i'm just saying men in general tend to
blame
others rather than themselves
when something goes wrong but maybe it's
not them
well in some cases i'm sure it's not
yeah so but in a lot of cases
well in in a lot of cases because in a
lot of cases
uh you know women blame themselves when
they shouldn't when someone else is
being an [ __ ] obviously
a lot of times like women will blame
themselves like maybe i did something
wrong even when the other person is
being a dick's man it depends though
but it's kind of like you don't really
know it depends though i have seen the
situations where women have blamed
themselves and [ __ ] from there
and depending on how you look at it it
could have been they could have been
[ __ ] partially to blame for
everything is everything is just opinion
opinion and [ __ ] perspective it's
hard to tell sometimes
it's hard to tell what truth is i don't
really believe in truth that much
i just know what happens and what
doesn't because the interpretation of
what happens and what doesn't happen is
often [ __ ] depend on who's seeing it
sondra says i know two men personally
who killed themselves both went quietly
with his little mess in every regard as
possible
uh i think it depends on the reason why
you want to go yeah um i
actually did i knew a dude um i knew
he was a friend of mine in high school
and
i found out that he killed himself like
a year or two after graduation
and he uh he did shoot himself
in the head but he did it
in a way he did it in his room and he
like wrapped himself
up in a sleeping bag i think it was and
then like shot himself in the he wanted
his dad to find him
but he didn't because him and his dad
like uh did not get along
so he but he didn't take anybody else
out he didn't do anything like that
um he just like did it very quietly like
in his
room so yeah and tila says women have
gripes and a right to anger so just stop
yeah
pretty much i mean i don't know i just
kind of feel like every time like women
express
anger or anything like that we get like
[ __ ] you know
i don't know it's just you were kind of
saying the same thing about men though
too though
yeah but the thing about yeah but what
we're discussing
is a dude allegedly that decided he
wanted to kill himself
which okay fine that's your choice
but he also decided to take 230 odd
innocent people who were just
on a plane of course going to beijing
with him
and it's like that is not justifiable in
any [ __ ] stretch the magic of course
i don't care how angry you are i don't
care how much people pick on you
i don't care about any of that [ __ ] i
just don't listen to her getting all
hyped
no i'm just saying i know the [ __ ]
was crazy you don't have the [ __ ]
right to do that
he was [ __ ] crazy rights have nothing
to do with it do what's crazy
well yeah but i'm just saying i'm just
saying that like
dudes like dudes like in general
when dudes kill themselves and like i
said we've seen it thank you gadgey3
because i forgot to say hi i blame the
yeagers this kind of [ __ ] is not [ __ ]
normal
all right [ __ ] you you won't thankfully
most dudes don't do this now i don't
ever want to fly on a plane but the
[ __ ] was crazy
you know what i mean you're getting
you're getting all [ __ ] bent out of
shape about it the dude was crazy
i'm not bent out of shape i'm just
saying okay but it's just kind of like
well the thing that worked the thing
that worries me
is that it's the same thing it's the
same [ __ ] crazy [ __ ] [ __ ] we have
a woman who she goes crazy and drowns
her three kids in the bathtub
because of postpartum depression it's
[ __ ] hormones have something to do
with it but
[ __ ] was crazy too well yeah well and
the thing about it like i said
we've talked about this before because
we talked about a lot of serial killers
on the show
yeah what's up focus when women are
killers uh with the exception of alien
warnings
um you know and a couple others but when
women are killers they usually tend to
kill
children people close to them yeah uh
children their husbands old people dead
people old people like people yeah
so people that are known to them uh
people they can
whereas dudes seem a lot more
comfortable just killing like random ass
people
oh they're crazy yeah but i'm just
saying that
dudes like that that's normal dudes i
mean it's not normal
well yeah i'm not saying kids well no no
one's saying any of this is normal
you're extrapolating that dudes and
dudes like it's just dudes it's just
men do that no these [ __ ] are
crazy
i mean the fact that you get like upset
about it i'm not talking about you
i'm not talking about i'm not saying i'm
not saying you are don't get offended
you're just saying don't be attacking
minutes
you know what i'm saying yeah it's not
it's not it's not men
it's easier i'm talking about like dude
serial killers all right we're just
straightening that
women's serial killers honestly when i
said the [ __ ] did i not just say women
tend to do this
yeah you didn't say not all women you
just said not all dudes
so you know this would be crazy and i'm
not talking about all
i'm not talking about all dudes
obviously i'm not talking about all
women obviously
obviously okay the fact that y'all get
like all so
upset about it is just that's um
how would you want another drink sure
okay see drinking too much once more
let me give you another that's only my
second one you've had like yeah that
[ __ ] was like a [ __ ] triple
tom is offended he is of course i'm
offended that [ __ ] was like [ __ ]
shrimp
but he's allowed to say shitty stuff
about women all the time
i'm not allowed i don't say shitty [ __ ]
about women are we talking about
i don't say anything i don't say
anything i'm not allowed to be offended
with a breast like that i'm going to say
some [ __ ]
yeah it's [ __ ] pretty no no no no
it's [ __ ] creatures of beauty
creatures of beauty sure whatever you do
you want the same thing
you want uh you want coconut in it let's
try the coconut let's see what that
tastes like okay
cause that was the same that was cherry
it was cherry yeah it tasted like
chicken
yeah that's the thing but it was
i don't know in a way i was reading
about this
story like i said i'm horrified anything
to do with a plane crash
is gonna like put my anxiety right
through the [ __ ] roof because i do
not
like flying in planes um
and i will try to avoid it whenever
possible actually i would be happy if i
never had to fly in a [ __ ]
plane ever again uh that'd be totally
fine with me
i just don't like it um you know i have
to drink a lot before i get on i just
don't want to even know that i'm there
and so
the fact that you don't even have to
it's
it's not just the fact that just like oh
i have to worry about mechanical failure
or i have to worry about a terrorist
attack or a bombing or like a missile or
whatever
and it could be yes it's rare
but it could be that there's just one
dude who's a pilot and he's totally
normal
in every regard and nobody saw the [ __ ]
coming
and then he decided on this one
particular flight on this one thank you
particular random night that didn't have
anything to do with anything
i am gonna kill myself tonight and i'm
gonna kill all these people
with that just like oh i watched like so
many documentaries about this and i'm
like i was saying to myself the whole
time like this is so [ __ ] creepy this
is so [ __ ] creepy
because you don't know those 230
whatever people that got on that plane
they just thought hey we're in malaysia
we're going to like china we're going
back home or we're going to job or
whatever the [ __ ] we were doing we're
going vacation like some of the people
from australia were
it's like we're doing that and you had
no idea
that the pilot of this plane was
like had this whole [ __ ] elaborate
plan can you imagine
god you're telling me my hair is
gorgeous and beautiful thank you very
much
my hair is gorgeous you're so gorgeous
and beautiful where are you calling me
victor says i love flying i love
chilling at the airports people watching
all that
i love airports honestly i really like
airports i don't know why
but i hate [ __ ] flying i hate it i
wish i loved it but i don't you see
sandra [ __ ] hit that [ __ ] right on
the net
says tom you gave her the test you gave
her that testosterone makes her ass wild
yeah it does makes her wild
it's i think it's i think he's mean
before though no he makes you wow
it makes you well okay it makes you what
it hasn't fully kicked in
it's i got it's a female dose it's very
weak but
it has a different effect on women i'm
just waiting to see
wait to see what happens dc says tom and
jenny i thought you all drank a lot
but i was in florida a couple weeks ago
key west orlando pensacola
yeah and had to drink twice as much as
colorado to get drunk
yet at high altitudes you don't have to
drink as much yeah
so we're at we're at sea level yeah so
that's that's the excuse we're going to
see today
i would love to go down to key west down
there [ __ ] and just be like a beach
bum but jenny hates that kind of [ __ ]
so if i would be down there people well
key west is cool though i'd be out there
[ __ ] like getting sun and [ __ ]
with i'm not gonna lay out in the sun
oh i'd get in the [ __ ] sun i'd have
[ __ ] get skin cancer
i'd have like a [ __ ] drink with an
umbrella in it
i'd [ __ ] be hanging out well i like
that yeah i'd be out [ __ ] hanging out
with [ __ ]
michael caine and the little boy from
the island wait is he still alive
no he's dead i think michael ducane
might be alive i'm not sure zombie
michael king
yeah we'd be out there [ __ ] talking
about the island and [ __ ] going out
on [ __ ] boats and [ __ ]
snoop dogg will be there [ __ ] we'll
be smoking blood [ __ ]
even though i like key west though yeah
i like some kind of
aspects of that um you know i like all
the kind of like coastal
like seafood type which i like all that
kind of stuff yeah it's just i don't
really
like oh let's just like lay on a beach
and cook for like five hours i like that
kind of [ __ ] sometimes no
well i grew up like that i got certain
things so you got certain times
certain times in your life where you
might have to do that gotta take a
[ __ ] break
michael caine's still alive says he's
still laugh yeah yeah i couldn't
remember michael king is the [ __ ] man
you made me put on my michael kane wig
no i've been looking too pretty to put
michael
i'm telling dc i actually went to
colorado
uh a few years ago because my sister
used to live there in denver
and i noticed that too now one of the
first things when i got there i was
totally fine
the next day i got really really bad
altitude sickness because like i said
most of my life i've lived at sea level
so
you know going up to that like mile high
or whatever
um i felt really really weird and i felt
really really uh
vomity let's call it that uh so you know
so i couldn't really eat much
like i ate and i would throw up and it
was all this other kind of stuff but
after i got over that
my sister like took me up in the
mountains and like we saw the
uh where they uh filmed the exteriors
for the overlook and all that kind of
stuff and then like we went up in the
mountains and it was
amazing i don't think i've ever seen
mountains like that close up like
as big a mountains i've been to like you
know whales and stuff they have
mountains there but not like
colorado mountains like where you go up
in the mountains and there's like clouds
are like below you
t's telling xanada about [ __ ] the
movie the hand
all right michael kane is i guess i've
been showing so many cool movies to
xander offline you know [ __ ] we pm
each other
or dm each other direct message you guys
got new ways of saying that [ __ ]
so um i showed him road warrior
[ __ ] mad max 2. he loved that [ __ ] i
said man you got to [ __ ] watch fury
road
and it's hard he has a hard time getting
around to it he's a millennial they got
a real short attention span
attention span of like a gnat or a
goldfish
but that one [ __ ] pulled him in he
liked that one
well i love him he couldn't get through
he couldn't get through
[ __ ] conan too well he liked he loved
[ __ ] apocalypse now that changed his
that changed his whole [ __ ] life he's
like oh and now i see what a movie is i
said yeah apocalypse now it's
[ __ ] because it's real there's no cg
going on
well the hand was kind of like michael
caine's version of the apocalypse now
in a certain way it
the hand was about an abusive
[ __ ] man and
conan's referenced in it because right
stone oliver stone did the hand and
oliver stone
wrote their original conan [ __ ] um
script and he was friends with milius so
he likes
he likes milius then you'd like stone
oliver stone's [ __ ] great
watch the hand then there's another
another michael caine movie called the
island
it's about florida and he [ __ ] finds
some pirates in florida pirates
they're real pirates from the [ __ ]
back in the day
also david warner david warren's david
they're inbred pirates from back in the
day living on a damn island
[ __ ] and they were stealing
everything off the damn cocaine
boats it's a trip man that's another
good one
that [ __ ] scared me man early 80s when
that came out
that [ __ ] movie scared me um but yeah
you want to see in the hand scared me
too
but michael caine was a is a legend
freaked me out when i was a kid
well i brought this up before any kind
of movie that had like any kind of
dismemberment
particularly decapitation but not always
it could be like an arm or a hand that
got cut off
um that really really scarred me as a
kid
michael kane was not a physically
powerful man but he was a spiritually
and emotionally powerful british dude
he always felt like he was one drink
away from [ __ ] slapping the [ __ ] out
of you
that he was like oliver reed yeah oliver
reed also
those two dudes right there legendary
british drunks
and they were both they were both kind
of drank a lot
of the readings well they were kind of
and the fact that they were known for it
back then
yeah is kind of impressive because kind
of everyone was a yeah
back then yeah everybody drank and
everybody did drugs but
so if you were like drunk drunk enough
to be like
commented upon by other drunks then you
were honestly like the pinnacle
of drunkenness oliver reed was another
one who was a good british actor that
was [ __ ]
one drink away from [ __ ] whipping
your ass we just rewatched
burnt offering yeah really because uh
shutter just added it yeah
and i wanted to rewatch it again anyway
because i've seen that movie a billion
times but i just reread the book
like because i did the review like a few
years a few weeks back
and then i wanted to rewatch the movie
again because i wanted to see like how
similar it was
and i forgot how much i love that
[ __ ] movie i love that [ __ ] movie
it's so good read when you were a kid
read was [ __ ] scary i see him now i
understand him a lot more as an adult
but when you were a kid you know in your
early teens or your teenagers he was
impressive they were both very
impressive dudes oliver reed in a
certain way was kind of like
he was kind of like
kind of like a non-heavy metal version
of [ __ ]
a [ __ ] um a [ __ ]
lead singer from iron maiden they always
kind of reminded me of
what was his name bruce dickinson he was
kind of like
bruce dickinson but a bigger yeah
and uh i liked him though [ __ ] you
had to be there at that time
it was a england had a
pretty strong influence over 80s
american culture
because of the british new wave of the
music
but the the film too um
they were they would put those guys in
american movies
big budget american movies it was a good
time it was a really good time
to be american probably a really good
time to be british too
the 80s and the 70s were the [ __ ]
if you if you were the right people if
you were the right people it was before
youtube
there's a lot of gatekeepers everything
was centralized you had to go through
certain studios and you just couldn't
well but i kind of feel like in the 70s
in particular and we've kind of like
brought this up before
in the 70s i kind of feel like there was
more even big studios were more open to
experimental experimental [ __ ] yeah um
after the 80s came along they're like no
we just want money so it's just like
that we want everything like formulaic
but in the 70s they were kind of like
willing to kind of go out on a limb and
experiment
well it's because there was cable wasn't
the competition in the 70s
there was a lot more theater so you had
to make a lot more movies
so um a lot of the experimental 70s [ __ ]
of the 70s
would have just ended up being youtube
movies of today
something that you put and i have seen
some good youtube movies
just i'm just gonna tell you that one of
the uh
a review that i just did that i think is
gonna go up
i guess is going up thursday or
wednesday if you're a patreon
i uh watched the movie it's steven
soderbergh
and it's unseen that whole movie was
shot
on an iphone 7. yeah and honestly i did
not
notice um other people probably did
i'm sure but i didn't know that going in
because i just like heard it was a
good movie it was stephen soderbergh and
i love him because you know sex lives on
videotape come on
uh also he did the oceans 11 movies but
whatever and so
like i watched it and it was really good
and then
later when i was researching it they
said oh the whole thing was shot on
iphone 7 and i was like okay
it was a little bit it was a weird
aspect ratio but i didn't really
like notice anything otherwise maybe i'm
just dumb
yeah i don't know
um yeah so uh gramster's hammer says
riley keough was in fury road riley was
in the girlfriend experience
with marilyn ricegum okay tom was in
joseph in the
technical dreamcoat with maryland yeah
tom has one degree of separation
from riley keough yeah who was in the
fury road movie yeah
there you go yeah i know everybody santa
says i just don't have time
to watch all these movies i kind of feel
like
man i scroll through like whenever i'm
doing the
the polls and stuff like that for
patreon
i'm always kind of like i try to come up
with like like what's available right
now i want some old movies i want some
new movies and i try to put all that
stuff in there
but it's like when i go through all the
streaming services that i subscribe to
shutter
amazon prime hulu to be whatever
there are so many movies in there that i
want to see
and that i haven't seen yet it really
like
sometimes it like overwhelms me yeah
because i'm like
oh [ __ ] i haven't seen that yet oh man i
gotta watch that like somebody told me
to watch that and then
like not only that but it's like i have
a [ __ ] pile of books i gotta [ __ ]
read
i'm only one to i'm only one degree away
from kurt russell
i'm directly in the [ __ ] crustal
sphere
because um a guy who's a listener who um
i went to military school with did the
sound on escape from la
and bone tomahawk and i think um
also um had something to do i think he
told me that he had something to do with
um
i was the one where he was driving in
the car right now breakdown
yeah i think he was in that one too i
think but i know he was
he sent me pictures of him in crustal
and [ __ ] escape from new york escape
from la
and bone tomahawk so um
yeah i'm in the crustal sphere deep deep
in the crustal sphere
that sounded dirty deep deep in the
ground he said i just imagined you like
he said i'd get along with he said i'd
get along with crusoe
he said russell's awesome everybody says
he's a nice dude yeah we were talking
about guns and
whatever you know [ __ ] crustles into
all that [ __ ]
he um when they had him on um i think it
was uh
another guy that i knew was doing doing
a uh a um
i think he's he's a sometimes listener
he's doing a uh
documentary about the movie soldier and
he had some of the guys that worked on
soldier with him
and they said that when they were doing
that movie they did like a poll
on everybody in the cast of who they
wanted to to be
sold be uh todd from the movie soldier
who was kurt russell kurt russell came
in as the most
liked actor out of all the crew
it said that nobody disliked him
everybody at least
thought he was okay or liked him a lot
so kurt russell is one of the most liked
actors in
hollywood
yeah well he like i said he comes across
as just like a genuine
he's genuine yeah he doesn't come across
as like an [ __ ] or like he's trying
to be something he's not
everybody says he's real solid he's just
like a solid regular guy
a regular cool dude not you know he's
not a regular guy right a guy might be a
[ __ ] deuce you know maybe just like a
solid cool dude
everybody likes him yeah he's not
deceptive or two-faced
well yeah that's what you got to do yeah
no
all right uh where were we uh you see
how many degrees from btk
i don't know i don't think i out hmm
ooh we'd have to like figure that out
yeah wouldn't we
yeah santa says i like historical films
though i'd probably like jfk i'll watch
it
jfk is good but
don't take it like it's historical fact
because a lot of it is like
wildly exaggerated but it's a good movie
if you as long as you don't like think
it's real you know what i'm saying
yeah because it's a little crazy but
it's a good movie
okay dc says tom i'll make it my mission
to get you zero degrees i don't know how
but
okay dc is the guy who um i believe i
think he changed his screen name
but that's the guy i went to uh military
school with
i think yeah
he knows him senator says thanks for the
disclaimer
senator said thanks for the disclaimer
yeah or just like as long as you don't
watch it and think like oh [ __ ] this
[ __ ] really happened because a lot of it
is like
jfk oh yeah because a lot of it is um
distorted or exaggerated or you know
we'll call it we'll we'll call it like
artistic license yeah let's call it that
[Laughter]
i'd love to have kressel on the show
[ __ ] we'll [ __ ] blow the [ __ ] up
crustle comes on we do a whole crustal
show talk about all of his movies
gram there's hammer says carrie raider
yeah btk's daughter
yeah lives in orlando go to crime con
this year
and that will be one degree of
separation
hmm honestly like i was gonna do crime
con
last year before the pandemic [ __ ] and i
was like planning a
booth and then we were like talking
about it because i kind of got asked to
do it
and then you know it didn't happen and i
was just kind of like
it would cost us too much to do it
anyway and i don't think it'd be worth
it
yeah um because it was really expensive
like to get a booth and everything
but interesting i'd like to go
one of these days if the tickets aren't
too expensive
just saying yeah so we about wrapped up
with this
i suppose so yeah it's time for us let's
get something to eat i'm drunk and
hungry
yeah we'll make you some deep drunkardy
i'm making drunky yeah i'm making
something that's it i got those
i just coined that [ __ ] i got those
hamburger patties
sound good you're gonna make a hamburger
yeah sound good
all right i'll toast the buns and
everything toast them in a pan
oh my god he's gonna toast butter he's
gonna toast the bun yeah
with cheese and bacon bits
well don't get too crazy okay make that
[ __ ] rare
i like them yeah they're frozen patties
i don't know if i trust them rare you
know i mean if it was
if it was good hamburger and i'm not
gonna die it's all right
[Laughter]
all right but yeah so i kind of feel
like i covered most of the [ __ ] right
yeah i'm pretty sure like i said i know
there's a lot of crazy theories out
there
i'm pretty convinced that
the captain sahari decided
for whatever reason that he was going to
take himself out it sounds like there's
a good chance
yeah and it's like so i not only decided
to kill 230 odd people
but also decided i'm gonna like put this
plane in the ocean
in a place where they're probably will
not gonna or not gonna find it
which shitty okay um
hopefully one of these days they find
this [ __ ] wreckage
i mean i feel like at least for the
family's sake so they can
at least have some closure so they can
find the bodies they know what happened
to the people
and they have something you know
because i think when i watch the
documentaries like a lot of the
survivors were like i wish
i just had a body that i could like say
goodbye to um because they know that the
people are dead they know that
but they're better to see yeah but it's
like well you know they didn't want to
be there like in the middle of the
indian ocean that really wasn't
where they would have wanted to be so
hopefully one of these days they'll find
it they probably will eventually
um they know roughly where it's at it's
just
it's a big place to search so we'll see
how it goes
so i guess i think we covered everything
right yep
yeah yeah all right so thank you
everybody for dropping by
sandra says wow i made it through the
whole show and didn't fall asleep
glad i didn't fall asleep
i might after this though but i'm hungry
so
thank you everybody for dropping by have
a good weekend
we will see you guys sunday we'll
probably be talking about midsummer
right because we just watched that
again and i know we already kind of did
a matinee on that
but when we saw in the theater but we
just rewatched it so we'll probably like
talk about it again on sunday
so we'll see you guys then thank you
everybody drum by thank you
everybody for your uh super chats
and everything conversation it's always
super fun
so we will see you guys on sunday
afternoon
and we will see you guys then bye